[Music]
yeah please help welcome some of our
home team members starting with the biz
doc himself Tom as well
[Applause]
[Music]
watch me imma prove them wrong I know we
feel my pain but still they kiss and
next Miami's most eligible bachelor put
your hands together right now for Adam
sauce
[Music]
certainly not least the reason why we
are all here the face of
Entrepreneurship businessman CEO of
valutainment the Assyrian lion put your
hands together right now for Patrick
Davis
[Music]
naked
how you feeling
all right
by the way what a show we gonna have
tonight talk about timing with what
happened this week and we got our guests
here tonight to talk about what what
what went on and what is it like uh 40
miles away from here something happened
in New York the indictment we got two
special guests here with us one of them
uh has got billions of views online
everybody loves this guy he went from
being an intern for Jon Stewart comedian
intern Jon Stewart then all of a sudden
to Reuben report okay millions of
subscribers and then I think he holds a
record if I'm not mistaken you know
usually when you move to Florida it
takes about 10 years for you to be
called a Florida man he loves Florida so
much he was able to do it in less than
12 months give it up to the one and only
Dave Rubin
[Applause]
[Music]
yes yes yes yes yes
and in this next one you guys are from
New York anybody from New York here yes
or no how many lived in New York you
were glad when this man cleaned up the
streets in New York yes or no how many
would like to see the same kind of
cleaning up happen a little bit and
maybe a city like San Francisco which we
heard what happened the tragic event
that happened the day ago in San
Francisco maybe in Chicago with
Chicago's leading in a lot of a lot of
many different things not not any good
stats they want to be leading in or New
York or some of the places that's going
on uh this man uh is called the
Americans Mayors uh mayor he has a lot
of exp I don't think we were talking
earlier at the house I don't think there
are a lot of people that have enough
experience as much experience as him to
talk about the events that's taking
place right now with the indictment and
before as a quick shout out to Andrew
Tate before there was a top G
the FBI used to give an award and they
used to call it the G-Man honor okay
which he got in 2015 a year before he
decided to support this man what's his
name his name is Donald I think is what
his name is Right Donald J Trump
president Donald J Trump so the original
top G mayor Giuliani Give It Up
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
let's get this here let's get the show
started oh my God we got so many
different topics folks if you're
watching us from uh around the world
welcome to the Pod we wish you were here
with us in about a couple hours when
we're done with the live on YouTube
we're gonna do some q a here questions
you'll get a chance to ask the mayor and
Dave a couple questions and then
afterwards we'll go to the Cigar Lounge
in the back we'll do some pictures we'll
have some conversations rumor has it
this man here not rumor has it he is a
big fan of cigars so we're gonna see
what's gonna happen with that but we got
a lot of things going on Dave some will
say you're more part of uh the
governor's camp or you're more
supportive of Governor Ron DeSantis
which is great and you've spent more
time with him you've interviewed him
multiple times you've done a lot of
different events with him he's a big
supporter of you you're a big supporter
of him which is fantastic and mayor
you've spent more time I want to say
with President Donald J Trump so it's
going to be good to get different
perspectives from both of you guys and
then how many guys love Adam and uh this
Doc in here as well to see what
perspective
so let's get right into it so
open-ended question when we're hearing
the stories right now uh with
some people saying what happened this
week in New York you know some people
from the mega crowd are saying this is
the they're using the justice system to
weaponize and go against the candidate
to eliminate them that's some people
that are part of the Maga camp that are
saying this
some on the Republican side are saying
this is a full-blown distraction because
they want to make sure that President
Trump beats out the scientists because
he's going to win in the primaries but
they don't think he can win in the
general election going up against Biden
or whoever else may be and then there's
people on the left that are saying No
this man is a criminal this is the right
thing to do we have to go after him
mayor Giuliani what do you have to say
about that I
can um figure out all the motivations
of a group of people that starting in
about 2015 2016
decided they were going to destroy
Donald Trump
so this is like chapter six or seven in
the same book which is let's frame
Donald Trump
let's get rid of them any way we can it
began with Russian collusion remember
that that was like three or four years
so we've concluded Russian collusion
about as clearly as we can
and it's real simple he was telling the
truth and they were lying
not only were they lying they spent well
over a million dollars to frame him
which means to try to put them in jail
for something he didn't do he had no I
was involved in his 2016 campaign as
much as anyone I was with him almost
night and day for about five months I
knew from the beginning of the Russian
collusion charge was completely
fictitious I didn't know
the rest of it that Hillary paid for it
that it was made up in the Ukraine the
guy who wrote the steel dosing hadn't
been in the Soviet Union for 17 years I
mean it was a ridiculous thing but just
think about it all these people were
involved
in framing him to stop him
when that didn't work they tried to
execute him acute a coup right get him
out of office and then we had the uh
phony Ukraine story
and then then we had um the suppression
of the hard drive I was the one who got
the hard drive
from John Mack Isaacs as the last last
person the only person who would take it
he offered it to two or three Republican
Senators
to the FBI the FBI buried it for a year
and a half
then we went through January the January
6 Insurrection the only Insurrection
ever attempted without a single firearm
without any plans to take over the
government
without any plans beforehand to do it
but they still call it an insurrection
and nobody prosecuted for Insurrection
nobody even charged with Insurrection
and they spent about 70 million dollars
on the investigation and they're
imprisoning people
endlessly
for basic trespass at worst
there probably were more FBI agents
involve than Mega people inside the
capitol if you ever get a chance to see
the 40 000 hours of tape that they are
suppressing
uh so this is just another attempt to
destroy him with phony completely phony
allegations
I don't know how well calculated it is
whether they want him to be the
candidate they don't want them they want
to destroy him anyway if they can
destroy them now they'll destroy him now
if they can keep him out of the I really
don't think they particularly want him
in the election for this reason
no matter how they calculated there's
only one way he can become president
he's got to get the Republican
nomination so if you can deprive him of
the Republican nomination you can stop
from being president
they got to be smart enough to know you
can't calculate who you can beat and who
you can beat
so if they help them to get nominated
their worst nightmare could occur
the only way they can prevent their
worst nightmares to stop them which is
what they really want to do any Democrat
that actually thinks well I want to
nominate him is a fool
how many times I mean Jimmy Carter
wanted to run against Ronald Reagan and
Ronald Reagan beat him in a landslide
and Hillary wanted to run against Donald
Trump
we know what happened right
so I don't I don't buy that one I do I
do buy the fact that they want to uh
stop him
whenever and however they can so you
don't think it's that strategic to want
to eliminate the Santas as a candidate
because on some polls it shows better
when DeSantis goes against Biden that he
can beat him but Trump against Biden he
can that's what a lot of uh polls are
saying I don't think right maybe it'll
maybe it eventually will be that as we
get closer to the election it's too
early to know who can beat who well no
we brought you here to tell us to we
want to know now we don't want to wait
Dave what do you have to say about this
well first off I'm regretting the amount
of tequila I drank backstage
I didn't realize they were actually
going to be people here so this changes
everything
I don't have my tequila now yeah
um well you know look on the on the part
are they trying to get Trump and is this
all about the election the answer
obviously is yes I should also say that
I like Trump I've interviewed Trump I
voted for Trump I was living in La when
I voted for Trump which cost me friends
and you know community and and that
whole thing I think he was by far the
best president of my lifetime uh and I
would gladly vote for him again in
certain circumstances uh relate so so
there's no air between us I would say uh
but on the on how outrageous this
situation is and obviously if the guy
wasn't running for president right now
they would never never be doing this
it's all about 24 it has nothing to do
with 34 trumped-up charges that are out
of the statue of limitations that uh
that really are nonsensical things for
the most part that now Stormy Daniels
owes him money on it and a whole bunch
more uh how does the prostitute end up
owing you money is kind of funny
yeah wow
thank you
okay
you must be really good yeah yeah you
were so good let me pay you for it you
mind if I tell them that he'll love that
and and you can use that line Rudy Trump
would love that and did you see in
Trump's statement today you know he
sends out these statements every day
he's sitting at Mar-A-Lago typing all
day he sends out this statement about
Stormy Daniels you know she owes me 120
Grand and he goes horse face Stormy
Daniels it's like dude you you hired her
it's like you know come on allegedly
Dave Legends of something yeah yeah
um and now he's doing a bad Yelp review
but all all of that
all of that being said in terms of in
terms of the real direction of the
country and yeah I've been in Florida
for 15 months I'm a refugee from Los
Angeles from California uh you know I
campaigned with Larry Elder to get rid
of Gavin Newsom who I think is in
Florida today do you smell him it's it's
you can that that stench you can get it
from Sarasota right now it's on the west
coast yeah right
um I got audited by the state three days
after the election so these These are
bad people that were fighting they
really are in terms of DeSantis and
everything else look what he has done to
this state I mean he has turned Florida
into the freest
like
Pat there's a reason you're here there's
a reason that every single one of your
employees has huge Smiles on their faces
the checks don't bounce and they live
here in Florida like it's all happening
here this is it truly it can't be
overstated Florida is the freest place
in the entire world and it is because
it's partly because of trump and setting
up a lot of this stuff and Florida has
had you know an interesting population
over the years but it's because DeSantis
fought the machine better than anyone
over these last couple years and and
beyond that I also think we just we need
a shift we need
it's not about age exactly but we we're
done I think being governed by 80 year
olds we need a generational shift I
think we need some Gen X people they've
just
there's people that are close to that
age in this room
and they seriously they shoot your
language they shouldn't be president
no offense my friend I'm just saying
you know we're I think we just we need a
shift we need we need a shift of
attitude we need a shift of Competency
you know I think I think the things that
we need right now are competency the
ability to communicate that and a Clear
Vision and and personally I think
DeSantis is the best guy the great thing
about today is you know uh you can
choose to identify as whatever you want
mayor can identify as a 42 year old you
can do that nowadays so for the next two
hours which are the 40
or the 38th I had I was on an airplane
called Dylan milvane I was once with a
with a lawyer who represents uh one of
the big transgender groups he's just
sitting next to me and he recognized and
we I I said explain it to me
uh two hours later I was ready to jump
out of the plane
I mean the things I can't even remember
how he was describing all these we got
down to about 22 genders
I think you know like you become son of
an you could become some kind of animal
or I mean it's completely insane it's
completely insane maybe he did have more
tequila than me yeah I'm not sure Willie
are you uh Rudy are you are you willing
to say publicly that there's only two
genders men and women
I
can't Define a woman I want to be on the
Supreme Court
I don't know
[Applause]
yes I want to say there were two genders
I even am willing to tell you how to how
I would identify them but I don't think
I should
so okay by the way that was a great
question by a guy who has two cats
tonight during dinner all we talk about
is the fact that Adam's a big cat guy
and he gave very good
question so it's starting to make a lot
of wisdom tonight around couch but
anyways let's go back to this let's go
back to this let's go back to this so
strategy wise okay Trump the Santa so
for you you're you're thinking there's a
part of this that there is weaponizing
of the justice system against the former
president perfect then then that that's
been that's been a while that goes back
to when they fixed Hillary Clinton case
then I then I have a question for you
because I think you're partially
responsible and and so here's where I'm
going with this and let's see what
direction you're going to take this so
we pulled up five historical facts about
weaponization federal government of
course we can go back to McCarthyism
where the you know communism they're
going against that 40s 50s we've all
know about that one then you have the
coin cointel Pro from 1956 to 71 the FBI
ran a covert operation known as
cointelpro which aimed to disrupt and
discredit various political groups
including civil rights activists on Top
This is the Malcolm X this is the Martin
Luther King then you have the War on
Drugs 80s and 90s they launched this
that led to a sharp increase in the
number of people incarcerated for drug
offenses then we have the Patriot Act
and prior to that you know we have the
RICO which you know the gentleman Blakey
who was a I think Notre Dame professor
in 1970 he came up with that and then
you guys kind of found a way on how to
go after the mob and then boom you took
down pretty much clean up the streets of
New York with the mob everybody was
trying to figure out a way to do it you
were the only one that ended up being
successful
you got the Patriot Act in 2001 which
the government passed this which
explained the government's ability to
surveil and investigate suspected
terrorists critics argued that the laws
has been used to infringe on the civil
liberties of innocent Americans that it
has been used to Target individuals and
organizations based on their political
views rather than their actual links to
terrorism and then you have the Mueller
investigation which happened in 2017. so
partially when you're doing this at the
beginning I'm assuming this is purely uh
speculating I'm assuming you're like hey
guys we got to take down the mob and
clean up the streets of New York we got
to do it no problem fantastic how are we
going to do it this guy comes in from
Notre Dame let me tell you this is one
thing that we came up with the
racketeering to recall act all this
other stuff let's do it then the
government said wow what a great weapon
to use against the people and then that
got stronger and more creative and then
some evil leaders got their hands on us
saying we can silence people how awesome
was this so even the original it was
used
to take the bad people out now it's
being used to hurt good and innocent
people how going back would you say
partially the RICO some of these things
you guys that do you regret any of it
making it as strong as it ended up being
that we're experiencing what we're
experiencing today well first of all I
don't know if all all of them are
related the same thing uh the difference
between then and now is every one of
those uh began as a legitimate uh issue
involving our national security our
safety they weren't nobody passed a
Patriot Act to go after innocent people
I mean this what's going on right now
was designed for one purpose and one
purpose alone for the ruling party to
take out the opposition party that had
no legitimate purpose at all the
weaponization of the justice department
was not to go after Mafia guys
terrorists people who kill you the web
possession of the justice department was
to destroy
a well really any opposition to the to
the regime
uh uh secondly any any law
can be misused there's I mean you can
miss you can misuse a
a minor misdemeanor
uh and weaponize it for filing false
entries in your books
so you're always subject to that your
subject the laws are there
uh it's like saying the Soviet Union had
a constitution
the red China has a constitution with
more right than our Bill of Rights
considerably more
but it doesn't mean anything
so I don't know that I don't know that
the government
even being excessive in pursuing bad
guys
and maybe even being a little bit
overzealous in doing that I don't think
that leads to what is now uh typical of
a totalitarian regime which is the
ruling party
using the criminal process to go after
the opposition party I think that's a
totally different thing and I think it
developed in a in a different way
I think it developed because of the
long-term influence of the Communist
party on the Democratic Party and I
think they've basically taken over I
think this is a well thought out plot
that goes back at least 20 or 30 years
to destroy our government and I think
that's why Soros is funding it why does
Soros pay for 40 or 50 DA's all over the
country to basically destroy these
cities
because Soros wants our government to
fall
he wants a one-world government
he probably wants to run the One World
Government or at least be the head of
the Department of the treasury
so he can steal from it and uh so no I
don't I don't regret the Ricoh statute I
think the RICO statute it would be
excellent to use for example against the
Biden crime family
it'd be probably exactly the whole idea
of the racketeering Act is
you just can't put them in jail you got
to take their property away
because if you just keep putting the
mafia in jail some other mafia guy comes
along and takes over the five billion
dollar Enterprise and it becomes 6
billion and it was a recognition by
Professor Blakey who I knew very very
well that the only way we're going to
crush the mafia is to take their empire
away for example one of the cases that
isn't mentioned that I did was I took
the uh Teamsters Union away from the mob
which meant taking Las Vegas Away From
the Mob because they controlled Las
Vegas to the central State's pension
fund
of the Teamsters Union
you thought it was a central State's
pension fund money it was the mafia
money that was being laundered for 30
years
um so I no I don't I don't regret it
what I do regret is the wrong people
getting in government and then being
able to use any of these laws but but we
can't but but we know the wrong people
are eventually going to be in power
right so you certain policies could work
for good people
because a good person may not abuse the
power that they have but you have to be
thinking about policies to create that
an evil guy doesn't come and say I want
to abuse my power so you know I
understand what you're saying it was
built for the good guy to you know find
and catch the bad guy but what if the
bad guy is now the leader that's going
after the good guy so what could we have
done differently the only reason I'm
asking this question is because we
gotten out this fed Now app coming out
we got cbdc coming out we got this
restrict act coming out that they're
saying are we going to take down Tick
Tock and Charlie cook made a very good
point the other day the fact that
they're using this to say they want to
silence Dave Rubin Dave we're sorry we
don't like the message you got we got to
go after him so so only thing I'm asking
is I'm not a lawyer I didn't work in the
New York you know District as an
attorney you've been around the block
for the next people the next Giuliani
the next guy that's going to have that
kind of a power when they're writing
these acts up should they do it or don't
even do it don't even go there but if
they do do it what what how do you
decided to make sure Bad Guy cannot
weaponize it bad guys can weaponize
anything
they can weaponize the simplest law or a
complex law and you can't deprive
yourself of laws that are going to
protect you against murderers rapists
terrorists you can't um
you can't pass a law that can't be uh
misused by by uh by a bad guy if a bad
guy gets into into power
uh it is this is not a question of the
laws that we passed it's the question of
the people that we voted for like uh the
people of Chicago
they've got to be something wrong with
him voting for the person they voted
Lori Lightfoot
he's talking about Johnson there's got
to be something wrong with them they're
brainwashed uh
this this is a this is a development
that happened within politics rather
than within the the legal system because
even if we didn't have these laws and
most of these laws weren't even used by
the Democrats in weaponizing the Justice
Department they're much simpler laws
that they used or they make things up
the the indictment of trump is a
non-existent indictment it's a it's
known void it doesn't charge a crime
it charges a crime without explaining
the crime which would lead to the
dismissal of any other indictment the
judge should have dismissed should have
thrown it out as no one void I don't
know why his lawyers didn't get up and
refused to plead to it if I represented
him he never would have pledged to that
indictment I would have said this is not
an indictment it says here this was in
pursuance of a crime what would you like
me to do guess which one of the 1 000
New York crimes it is would you give me
a hint at least
what am I pleading to
if you read the indictment you don't
know what you're pleading to he's
pleading he if he pled guilty you
wouldn't know what you pled guilty to
so what do we can't do away with
indictments but we got to do is do away
with corrupt District Attorneys like
Alvin Bragg I mean that's that's the
problem
Dave what do you think well let me add
something to to slightly defend the
mayor from the time that he was in
office and beforehand when he was uh
when he was dealing with the mafia and
all this stuff when these laws were put
into place you know we used to have
Democrats and Republicans that disagreed
on on certain issues meaning taxation
certain things related to Crime certain
things related to abortion etc etc but
there wasn't one party that in essence
was solely existing to pretty much
destroy America as we know it and become
completely Lawless and not know the
difference between boys and girls and
want neo-racism taught in the schools
and not believe that jailing criminals
is correct Etc et cetera we now have one
party like that so I think what's
happening now you got a guy like Alvin
Bragg who we were discussing it at
dinner the guy does not uh charge you
with the crime if you jumped the Turn
Style in New York city so think what
you're doing you're doing two things
when you do that first off you're
incentivizing people for bad behavior
right you're telling them go ahead and
jump to turn style do whatever you want
and you're also telling the law-abiding
person in New York City you're a sucker
man you're paying your 250 or 275
whatever it is on the subway now while
while these kids are just jumping over
they will not prosecute for prostitution
the craziest one that they will not
process prosecute for is uh is avoiding
arrest so you are allowed to literally
fight the cop as he's trying to arrest
you and you will not be penalized for
that so I think what's happened here
there's a little asymmetry most of us
especially if you live in a free state a
Law and Order State like Florida where
by the way we are now getting all of the
good cops you know that there were there
were thousands and thousands of
incredible members of the New York
Police Department who are now moving
down here DeSantis is giving them
bonuses and we're becoming stronger and
they're becoming weaker the difference
is that when you have one side that is
completely unhinged related to law and
reality
there is no law that you can set up that
will not be abused I'm going to still
push back if you're okay with that guy
yeah and I want both of you guys to try
to rip apart my argument and I'm very
comfortable with that okay so you have
kids you have a family you're doing
estate planning you're doing living
trust okay and you would like to pass
down your wealth to your kids but you
would like them to manage the wealth in
a responsible way so can go to your
grandkids and great grandkids and stay
within the family right so when you
study generational wealth and you go to
Rothschild you go to Rockefellers you go
to Vanderbilts you go to Medici family
all of these guys you will see
Vanderbilts were so flipping wealthy but
his living trust sucked yeah I think he
had like 11 kids within one generation
or two boom all the money was gone
medicis kept it in the family I think
Seven Generations Rockefellers kept in
the family three generations I believe I
believe the way we create the laws we
can say let's not vote bad people in
here but okay can you be a great parent
and have one of your kids that meets a
teacher at UC Berkeley and flips them
and all of a sudden they become a person
that cannot agree with anything you're
saying in your evil parent and all this
other stuff and if you give that guy the
money he's going to go give the money to
so all I'm saying is we can't control
evil people we can't control people that
get influenced to do dumb things okay we
cannot control it even great parents
could have bad kids all I'm saying is
it's easy for us to put it all on Alvin
Bragg's but he was able to do this
because certain things in the past you
can go and say well in this case here's
what it is so guess what the way they
took this guy down let's just go and
Target Donald Trump the way they took
this guy down all I'm saying is while
we're going through a big decision right
now with this restrict act you're not
going to be affected by it you and I
will be affected by it but our kids will
be affected by it because they're going
to be the ones that's going to be using
social media a lot longer than we are so
we can sit here and be like well it's
not really ad we just got to make sure
we vote the right people in if it's all
about just voting the right people in
why are so many immigrants in America
they escape that I think there's a part
of it all I'm asking is mayor from you
and I want to transition to another
topic what can we learn from the way we
wrote these things up to not do it do it
again well maybe I didn't make it I
didn't I didn't point out this other
part of it I'm not saying there aren't
very bad laws
and that was a past that infringe human
rights civil rights are too intrusive
are unwise
can actually be more easily abused that
all happens and we shouldn't do that now
or before or later
I just don't think there's the
connection between that and what you're
saying I don't think Alvin Bragg exists
because let's let's say you believe that
the Patriot Act was overzealous intruded
too much into uh privacy and it might
very well I might agree with you on some
of that
um I don't think that's the reason we
are where we are today I think
independently we should fix it and
that's another problem that we have and
I think to restrict Act
I think it would be a very bad law and
it would be a particularly bad law
because our government has become more
corrupt
so we would be in the hands of corrupt
people but it shouldn't even be in the
hands of honest people and I think the
way we like I think the inheritance tax
is inherently
an inequitable unfair uh
anti-capitalism
anti-incensives to to to develop wealth
anti-human nature one of the reasons you
work hard is for your family
and then that's the contribution to
everyone because you're working hard
your main objective is your family but
you're helping society and doing that
and knowing that your wealth is going to
get cut in half or more
that's going to change it's going to
change that and then people are also
going to look for ways to break the law
these intrusive laws lead to a lot of
like if you have taxes that are too high
people find ways to avoid it and then
people find ways to evade it so I think
Patrick there are two I think there are
two different problems that you you're
talking about
and I think the problem I think this
problem emerges from our politics
or morality or lack thereof
um and I I do think and I know it sounds
like it this is a conspiracy theory that
I'm asserting but I am
it is a conspiracy I think that China
has a lot to do with it
I think China has corrupted many of
these people who are involved in these
uh uh
unbelievably illegal applications of the
law
if uh if
Biden isn't corrupted by China it would
be totally ridiculous the guy got 31
million plus dollars in the last six
years from China
and he's taken actions for China that
that only could be taken by somebody
that seems to favor China over the
United States he gives up an air base
400 miles from China
that's insane
in an era in which we may be in a in a
war involving missiles and airplanes
being 400 miles from China is an
unbelievable
strategic advantage
given away by our president for nothing
in return
aha
is it a coincidence that the man who did
it
family got 31 million dollars from China
in the last six years no it's not a
coincidence you have to be ridiculous to
think it's a coincidence
he refuses to pursue China and the other
cause of covet
he refuses to
he told us that
China China really is a friend
ultimately a friend he's never said a
harsh word about China
and they're they're eating they're
they're they're
day by day they're gaining an advantage
over us if they're not already
have an advantage that's going to take
them to what to their goal of being the
dominant Nation on on the Earth by 2048
I think that they'll get there faster
if I just had one other thing you know
your question basically boils down to
what do you do about unintended
consequences these people are trying to
do things that are going to create Law
and Order good incentives for good
citizens to do the right thing but there
are going to be bad actors the
libertarian part of me I'm completely
with you you can't you can't create
legal you can't create laws that in
essence are going to control people
perfectly humans are imperfect we can't
create perfect systems it's as simple as
that but I would also say that this is
the best argument for federalism for
what's happening here in Florida we we
can't the federal government I know this
isn't a federal case but we now have a
party in half the country that does not
believe in laws they they will do
anything they can to accumulate power I
am not saying that the right and the
conservatives and the Republicans are
great because they're they're pretty
crappy I always say on my show you don't
have to be a republican but you cannot
be a Democrat that that's my basic
position so it's not that they're yeah
it's not all right all right I'll take
it
it's not that the other side is so great
but there is a basic sense you know this
I mean I watch your show enough when you
bring on people on the right and people
on the left people on the right
basically can agree to disagree I have
no doubt if we pulled everyone in this
crowd the political opinions would be
all over the room and people would want
this tax and that law on abortion and
all sorts of stuff but there's a basic
sense that we believe that the system is
pretty good we can work within it let's
see if we can accomplish something and
on the other side it's gone so it's not
a perfect answer but I wonder do you
have a perfect answer to your question
okay so think about it this way so I
don't I don't have a perfect I bring
smarter people like you guys to make me
smarter that's that's how I live my life
right okay so but if you look at Forbes
Magazine at one point it was the best
business magazine we all went to right
until 2021 the international woman of
the year was Hillary Clinton okay so if
you you put her as International woman
business woman of the year is Hillary
Clinton I mean it confuses the hell out
of everybody at least he was an actual
woman yeah that's a good point yeah this
year could be
wouldn't that be funny if Hillary turns
out not to be a woman that would be like
would you be shocked
his son takes over Malcolm Forbes takes
it to the next level okay he calls it
the capitalist tool Malcolm's son Steve
Forbes takes it over okay 95 of Forbes
today is owned by China don't you think
if you're the guy that's like if I'm
selling valuetainment one day that I'm
gonna die and my kids are going to take
over there's going to be bylaws the only
person that can buy this company ever is
going to be XYZ or certain kind of
things to protect from somebody from
China buying valuetainment these are
things that we have to learn from other
people's mistakes there's gonna be bad
kids there's gonna be bad grandkids
there's gonna be somebody in the family
that's going to be a divider but if you
have certain things in the rules in the
constitution in laws that we put that no
matter how much the left than the right
one to fight this cannot be compromised
I'm just saying can we look into
something like that but let's transition
to another topic because we got a lot of
the other topics to go through here so
DeSantis uh Trump one of the
conversations that's been coming up is
uh the fact that hey uh Megan Kelly came
out the other day and said hey Rhonda
santis I'm not for Trump everyone knows
Megan Kelly is not somebody that's going
around you know promoting Donald Trump
we all know what happened what kind of
questions she asked the first question
we know this right okay
she goes out and says the scientist is
not going out there he's hiding you're
afraid to come and be interviewed by me
you're doing a softball interview but by
Pierce Morgan and we know Pierce Morgan
is more for you than it is for Trump
anyways I don't need to get into it so
then the conversation becomes on NBC or
some of these places like I'm not going
to go do the interview unless you say
you apologize for this or for that or
for this
is the strategy he's taken he hasn't
announced yet you know there's a lot of
things you kind of educated us about
Florida on some of the things which you
can share with the audience he has he
hasn't announced yet do you think he's
taken the right strategy right now not
going out there and doing a lot of
interviews yeah Dave I'll go to you
first well first off I just want to say
I I don't work for the campaign I've
never been given a day campaign manager
tell them the truth Dave so everybody
knows I work for tequila no I've never
I've never
I've never been given anything look I
again just to reiterate the reason that
I that I support the guy the way I do is
because I see what he has done to my
life and I S and I suspect that many of
you if you live in Florida are feeling
the exact same same thing and I just see
what's going on here uh relative to a
country right now that is upside down in
so many ways uh as for the strategy
related to that I mean the truth is I
don't know if he's running let's go on
the Assumption he's running for the for
the purpose of this conversation there
are some laws in the Florida uh
legislature that he can't he would have
to step down I mean he just won
re-election by an unbelievable Landslide
I mean don't forget the guy you know
four years ago he only beat Andrew
Gillum who turned out to be a meth
addict he only beat him by 30 000 votes
that's how close Florida got to
basically being Illinois or New York or
or California at this point you know
once you factor in covid so that's one
thing so he'd have to figure out some of
the legislative stuff which is you know
they've got a super majority here I
think that'll work itself out I think
the other part of this probably is you
know if you're the guy that that
from where I sit I think most people see
as the most competent public leader that
we have at this point a guy who also as
I said before the age thing he's I think
he's about 45 you know he's got three
kids he's a family man he come you know
all the think of all the people over the
last you know six years who would say
you know I I get Trump on the policy I
like the policies it's working the
economy's cooking peace in the Middle
East all that stuff I don't like the
tweets and the attitude right that was
the whole thing I don't like the Mean
Tweets well congratulations you got it
with this guy so the point is I think he
can bring over the independence I think
he can bring over the disaffected
Liberals like me like this guy uh like
probably some people in this crowd he
proved it here because he went from 30
000 votes to winning by about 1.6
million votes so I think he's the
crossover guy and but just to very
clearly answer your question in terms of
uh timing you know it's nice to make
people wait but at some point you can't
at some point you can't right but it's
nice to have people kind of going oh
you're the guy you're the guy and then
they kind of drag you in uh but I I
suspect the mayor might have a different
opinion on that uh no I I I actually
don't uh let me just take off my trump
hat and put on my political
expert hat
uh I don't know that it's a bad strategy
to wait bad in a horrible way no I don't
and I don't think that's the so one of
the reasons people would say that is if
a month or so two months ago look like
he was ahead now it looks like the Santa
says behind I don't think it has
anything to do with the sentence I think
it has to do with what they did to Trump
I think if if if they are trying to get
him nominated the Democrats they did I
mean they they did a real favor
I mean uh so he goes from being behind
to being anywhere from five to twenty
points ahead 30 points ahead and in many
national polls uh
and I so I if I were to stand as his
campaign I wouldn't look so much
I don't know there was much he could
have done so if he were appearing over
the last
uh month on uh shows and being
interviewed I don't think it would have
changed anything because it's not a
function of the status it's a function
of trump being in the minds of most
Republicans even the ones that don't
support him being unfairly treated
um
and I and I I my objective really and I
you know Trump's lawyer he's been my
friend for 34 years and I'd love to see
him be reelected and the main reason is
because he's already done it and I I
know how difficult the presidency is I
don't know it from having done it but
I've worked for Ronald Reagan and I I
virtually lived in the Trump white house
for two years as a lawyer
you never know and I I like DeSantis a
lot I appreciate him as an American I
appreciate him as a republican I don't
think there's anything he said about him
that isn't true in terms of
his abilities as a governor and maybe
some advantages he would have as a
candidate
um
but what I do know is I know exactly how
Trump will react
to the most difficult job in the
American president ever going to face
which is to take our government back
from it's already been delivered over to
socialism
if not totalitarianism in many respects
it's inbred within the federal
government the Deep State really exists
it is much much worse than I ever
thought
and when Trump became president I told
him how bad the federal government was
he probably didn't know
as much as I knew how bad it was
it I was telling him a fairy tale when I
was telling him that it is much worse
than I thought it's going to take a man
of tremendous courage to do it and he's
gonna have to start on day one
I have no reason to believe that Trump
that DeSantis can can't do that
but I've seen people once they get into
office into that office not be able to
do it and honestly nobody knows that
answer he could be a great Governor
terrible president
um I don't say that he would be if Trump
isn't a nominee I will support the
Santas
I probably will support any Republican
over a Democrat and I'll feel pretty
comfortable that he has a good record as
a governor therefore he'll be a good
president
but I won't be a hundred percent sure
that he'll be able to do all the things
Trump already did it he delivered peace
he delivered one of our most prosperous
eras that we had
he delivered the best economy for
minorities that they've ever had
he achieved uh
peaceful resolution or seem to be in the
Middle East
there's no there I don't think there's
anybody in this room that would doubt
that Russia would not have invaded
Ukraine if Trump were the president
just wouldn't have happened just think
of all those people to be alive today if
we hadn't made the mistake of electing
Mr demented I mean we would
no well just think of it I mean those
people would be alive today
today he put out his Afghanistan report
and he blamed Afghanistan on Trump
although Afghanistan is not necessarily
a mistake because we left
it's a perfectly reasonable decision to
leave
I think you could defend either decision
leave or stay
it's how we left
he handled how we left right
Trump didn't make the decision to take
out the troops before you take out the
civilians now I do I don't understand
that I will never understand that
decision there had to be somebody on his
staff even if he is demented that would
say to him Mr President we usually do it
the other way around
we leave the troops
so the civilians can leave and in a
country that's dominated by terrorists
who these civilians have been fighting
you basically get them all killed
I mean only a
I don't know I don't I don't even know
if you're owned by China why you would
do that except Gates saying that he
always makes the wrong decision about
foreign policy
isn't it makes the wrong decision about
foreign policy in addition to being
demented before he was demented he was
profoundly stupid and
no and he was put there because he's
profoundly stupid because he can be
manipulated
so
I I don't know if uh
I don't know if if I can take my hat off
a trump hat off and say descent if I
were running to Santa's campaign I'd
wait this out
I wouldn't there were times in which it
doesn't make sense to try to fight the
inevitable this is too big
for a candidate to take on what's going
on with Trump it's going to resolve
itself you got to have patience and then
that's the time for him to
move forward if that's what he wants to
do Pat at the end of the day I guess I
would say who do you think can bring in
more new voters who is where can Trump
go to find new votes if we're to believe
that the last election was legit now
Trump doesn't believe it was legit but
if we're all playing in the show that
the election was legit we know that he
got 75 million votes and Biden got 81
million votes despite the dementia and
everything else right so if we're if we
believe let's not forget the most
popular president of all time is Joe
Biden I mean we have to put the facts
it's incredible million votes yeah and
the ice cream and all of it Corn Pop
everybody
um but you know what it would be the
question you're asking I'll go to Adam
and here's why I'm going to Adam because
of what you said earlier you know we
we've spoken you've spoken at him a
couple times you know where he's at
politically when Adam and I first met at
an insurance conference years ago I
thought he was just a good looking guy
I'm like this is a good looking guy
going around trying to sell people
insurance right and I said hey why don't
you get on camera and do something right
and then the boom next thing you know he
calls hey pal let's get together to come
and join the value Timmy Timmy flies
from Miami to Addison the state is
staying with us for a couple years it's
not been two and a half years and I
asked him I said so tell me politically
where you stand what do you think about
Trump what do you think about all these
guys and his opinions
was very like there's no way in the
world you know Russia all this other
stuff Adam for yourself two and a half
years three years you've seen what's
happened okay you're not the biggest
Trump supporter you got a guy that you
got DeSantis here in Florida how do you
feel as an independent you used to be a
center left you're maybe in the middle
right now how do you feel as a voter
between Trump and the Santas well thank
you
um well number one what a great looking
crowd we got here just before I answer
this what if he pandered the crowd for a
second great to see everybody here
um but
um I think Dave's absolutely right
because for me it's all about upside we
know
that Trump's upside is 50 at best did he
ever reach above a 50 approval rating
ever he might have he might have at one
point but it's it's actually moon at
this point it's like where are the new
voters right now and um if the
Republican party wants to get
independence because
um that's what it's all about we all we
say this all the time on the podcast 45
of America's voting left 45 of America's
voting right there's nothing you could
do about it whether you're Bernie
Sanders whether you're Rudy Giuliani
they're going there so you got to figure
out the 10 percent
where are they willing to go and I think
um so everyone has
a Tipping Point with Trump in my opinion
so whether it was you know for me it was
the whole what do you thoughts about
David Duke he's like I don't even know
who David Duke is he's like he's the
leader of the Ku Klux Klan I don't know
that is there's everyone has a Tipping
Point and I kind of want to find out
when your Tipping Point was but for me
if you ask me like Adam what do you
stand for I'm just sick of Americans at
each other's throat half my friends are
Republicans half my friends are
Democrats and they're like all my
Republican friends are like
you're a freaking socialist liberal
whack job and all my liberal friends are
like you're a Maga supporting like crazy
person I'm like I'm just a cool dude
that lives in Miami they have two cats
can I just hang out with some chicks and
hang on my buddies like no you have to
pick a side it's like I don't want to
pick a side because I think both sides
are kind of ridiculous right now but
he's trying to say DeSantis very slow
yes you see what's happening here yes
just for me I think it's
what president or what candidate I know
you said that Santa's hasn't declared
yet you're not sure if he's going to run
he's going to run now you're not like
top of the polls and decide to pull back
what candidate can get to a 60 approval
rating and I say this all the time and
what can Donald Trump do to get north of
50 there's nothing that we've seen seen
that can get us there and I think
there's something to your credit there's
something about DeSantis whether it's
the youth whether it's the the way you
handled covet whether what he's done in
Florida that there's something so
attractive about the guy that even
though he hasn't announced his candidacy
yet people are still clamoring for it by
the way guys don't forget you know Joe
Rogan who has a pretty popular podcast
and obviously knew that Biden was broken
and this whole thing was fraudulent
Rogan didn't vote instead of saying I
was going to vote for Trump right so he
didn't want to take that risk but he has
since said that he would support
DeSantis Elon Musk who is a lifetime
Democrat has now said that he would vote
for DeSantis so it shows you that
something culturally Beyond just the
politics of who can change this vote and
you know what do you think on that
policy or what's going on with the trial
there's something else culturally going
on here where some of the taste makers
are finally being like boy I thought
that Republicans were supposed to be
these mean evil scary people who only
cared about money and War but actually
it's not the case and DeSantis is
modeling let me ask you a question
um what was the moment because you were
you know supporter of trump you voted
for Trump 16 and 20. no not 16. I voted
for Gary Johnson the independent really
because
voting booth yeah right so you came
around yeah yeah so you didn't go Joe
Jorgensen in 20 no why is why not joke
because by that point I really liked
president Trump and I completely agree
with Rudy the things that he just laid
out there but by the way historically
you know Joe Jorgensen is known as one
of the greatest Debaters of all time
retirement after going on
what happened on my show she goes
through an hour of explaining everything
and I'm like yeah you know I'm very
sympathetic to libertarian ideas and I I
voted for Gary Johnson and then she did
the stupidest thing you can possibly do
on a show like ours she goes so Dave are
you going to vote for me and I was like
no
no I'm voted for Trump so she just
walked she just laid and that was and
you can see the moment
you could see her die like slow motion
you know yeah what was the the the
moment where you cool shoes by the way
uh Aldo 75 bucks nothing saved our money
why don't you Adam this is this is the
more important part than what you're
talking about because while we're having
dinner here's what we learned from Dave
I think it's very important to all the
political strategists to pay attention
to this part because there may be a big
clue here they've pointed out that
typically dog owners are Republicans
and he pointed out that cat owners are
Democrats so one of the things that
Republicans got to think about is the
next time the scientist is doing an ad
he should pet a cat because some of the
people to be like hey you're a
republican you're a republican you're a
Republican and maybe you can convert
some based on what Dave you pointed out
tonight I thought it was a brilliant
strategy that's better political
analysis than you're gonna get on CNN
tonight so well I I will I will nominate
my two cats for desantis's campaign
rally what was the moment that you
officially said all right Donald Trump
thank you for your service I'm on the
DeSantis train now oh what was the
moment well that I was on The Descent
look again I like Trump so it's not it's
just from being here
yeah look I've seen it I've seen what
you all see in this state crime is not
running rampant taxes are low we have
lowest all-time unemployment here our
the biggest problem in Florida and I
asked the scientists this on the show a
couple weeks ago we have a housing price
problem because twelve hundred people
move here a day a million people in
three years it's it's roughly equivalent
to the million that left California so
it's it simply is a matter of seeing
something functional and competent and
you are voting for DeSantis my friend
so are you basically saying that if
Gavin Newsom was the nominee of the
democratic party there's no chance that
you would support your old friend
Governor Gavin news oh God this is where
Dave gets triggered by the way
I've never hated someone so much I don't
like I don't like having the feeling of
hate I I honestly you know people say
they're a lizard people I actually
believe he's a lizard person like I I
funded I believe he is he is a lizard
wearing the skin much like uh Silence of
the Lambs like he has created a human
body out of human skin and he's wearing
it yeah yeah lotion in the basket he is
an evil evil freak and I I would just
leave the country yeah
that would be it for me okay so let's
let's go to a different topic I I kind
of want to talk about that yeah of
course of course I think you're being uh
your analysis
is naive
it's much too early to know how good a
candidate DeSantis will be
uh he came out of the gate when they
first thought about I thought about him
very strong
he lost that lead very easily
as a political I mean I ran for
president I've been involved in four
presidential campaigns
the front runner usually loses the
nomination
usually that's more often than
wins it and if I were analyzing the
status I would say his initial lead
was ephemeral
not solid
because it wouldn't have been lost that
quickly with the indictment and the
whole thing and right now he's
substantially behind
and there are there are other candidates
as well and their object like you were
wondering why why does vivec go after
the Sanderson not Trump because he's got
to get past to Santa's
DeSantis is in a position where the
other Republicans will go after him
before they will go after Trump
because in order to buy with Trump they
have to become DeSantis
uh and and secondly there's no price you
pay in going after the Senate he's not
an icon of
40 of the people he's a good looking guy
he's a very good voice yeah but nobody
nobody loves him yeah
they just know him they don't ask me
voice you don't like the raspy voice
that's a sexy I was sent to Florida to
help him win
in in in uh in 18. uh because he was
losing to kill him the guy that got him
through was Trump
he got through on Trump's popularity oh
you're talking Newsome right now or the
same time
and he was not a particularly good
candidate you were talking about I'm
talking new I'm still on like news
by the way here's the other thing you
were doing here's the other not thinking
he's talking Newsome here's the other
question though for the Democratic side
okay go completely different angle so
you as a republican who do you want
running to give you the highest chances
of winning do you want it to be Biden or
do you think Newsom stands a better
chance no I think you're looking tall
well spoken goes to French Laundry
frightening you know
I think I think Newsom would be it's
hard to see this is so ridiculous
analyzing who's easier to beat because
usually the person you think is easier
to beat is the person who beats you
um the examples like uh Reagan and Trump
and probably others that I can think of
right now I would I would I'd worry
about Biden because it's so damn corrupt
and um
for some reason I mean he's unpopular
his unpopularity is up around 56 57 it
should be about 65 I mean he
there's still kind of an affection for
him that's scary I mean he is a terrible
president but let's put everything aside
the Santa is Trump everything's not
he probably is definitely the worst
president in my lifetime
uh he may be the worst president ever
I'm trying to think of a president that
hurt this country more than him in a
short period of time
got people killed because of his
incompetence like Afghanistan those
people would accomplished one of them
have just been Trump who would have said
no to taking out the troops uh before
this almost any sane person would do
that how about leaving uh 45 billion
dollars worth of lethal arms behind at
Pegram
air base in a country dominated by
terrorists who you know are going to use
them to kill your kill your own people
which they have done
that that decision can only be made by a
Trader or a Madman
I mean the guy has been a terrible
president
because there is something Mr Giuliani
no but there's something there's
something scary about him and being able
the American people don't register that
they watch them uh three weeks ago four
weeks ago he told the story about giving
his uncle the Congressional Medal of
Honor
uh his uncle didn't want it
uh and his father told him at his
inauguration his vice president that his
uncle had never gotten his medal so he
organized a big ceremony in the White
House and gave him the medal now here
are the facts his uncle never got the
Congressional Medal of Honor there's no
evidence of it anywhere his uncle was
dead for five years
before he was in the White House and his
father was dead for seven years before
he was in the white house
he repeated the story after being told
that a week later
so about two months the guy's delusional
do you remember about two months ago out
of nowhere he was given a speech and he
announced that he had cancer and then
literally everybody was like he doesn't
have cancer that's just the dementia
it's like that's
that's the level that we're at we should
be more unpopular yeah there's something
going on I mean he should be whatever
whatever he should have the highest the
highest disapproval ratings of any
president I want to I want to go to Tom
Tom for you we've been friends uh for 15
years you grew up you lived in Florida
Boca right around here you grew up
you've lived in Connecticut California
we've lived together in California Texas
and Florida we met in California you've
done very well in business Silicon
Valley you've been professor at Biola
pepper now you've done all this stuff
you're married you got two kids your
daughter's about to go to school your
wife is here with us when you're looking
at all the things that's going on right
now okay for yourself you got the santis
you got Newsome you got Trump I want you
to speak from the paranoid side because
you got a paranoid side as a business
person because we have to be or else
you'll go out of business from the
paranoid side what's keeping you up at
night saying this is my concern if XYZ
happen means we could be in the same
situation as we were two and a half
years ago what are you thinking well I
feel like I'm watching you know Japanese
Kabuki theater play out you know with
the media and the things that they're
they're they're they're they're bouncing
right now it says you know I look at it
and I say wow isn't it sort of
coincidental that a very well-versed
research group drops 500 pages of Oppo
research on the very day that the
indictment is finally dropped by a man
convinced by the Democratic party to
become a kamikaze pilot which is Brag
and I think that's basically what's
happened to us I think he's just
basically taken one for the team they
promising a book deal and that's what's
going to be right you're going to be out
of office you get a book deal just like
the Press secretaries do or you'll get a
show in MSNBC you're all going to be
good I look at it and I say wait a
minute what's going on that we see here
down below here this is a pretty
skillful game that's being played and it
bothers me and what it bothers me is
that we've velocity ability to
rationally debate one another over core
issues but protect the soil that we're
standing on that allows us to have free
speech and have that debate you know
that's my concern and what keeps me up
at night is like you know you're arguing
on a Podium that may be on fire and
you're both going to fall through if you
follow the the metaphor of course and
I'm like you know be careful what you
wish for and I I had you know I've had a
lot of liberal friends in California we
got along well we worked at the same
companies you know for five years you
know I had you know you know a gay boss
I didn't care you know was he a good
boss or not and we all got along there
was no animus on oh you're this you're
this there wasn't like this dividing
line like I feel like today if I had
that if I flip back the clock to be 30
years old again and had the same
situation would there be this different
vibe that's going on between people and
I think there would be and I think it's
terrible and what keeps me up at night
is that I look at my girls and say what
platforms are going to be tomorrow to
have rational discussions about people
with people about things that matter and
I think we need to have like a strong
leader rise up to be the president who
can basically pull people together but
do it from a period of from a position
of strength from a position of poise
from a position of leadership I mean one
of the greatest you know compliments
people gave Reagan and I go back on this
is when they said there are other
countries remember when they said he's
crazy what that meant was that they were
a little afraid of him and that little
afraid became respect because you know
what it's not that he might push the
button and blow up the whole World with
nukes but he was willing to take you
know Kaiser sose move the one move that
the other guy wouldn't and it kind of
keeps saying some balance or strong
leadership so it keeps me up is waiting
for strong leadership to emerge and
waiting for America to come back do you
think there's a chance that Biden or
Newsom gets uh uh in the White House in
2024 like is there a concern that one of
those two could be in the White House in
22. yeah my concern is that what they're
doing here is inflaming a wing of the
GOP to give Trump enough juice to win
the primary because I think that they
are scared spitless of a moderate
candidate with potential like the Santa
got it I think they're terrified of that
how many guys feel that way by the way
how many guys feel the way he's saying
right now really really okay very in by
the way just out of curiosity how many
of you guys don't have that concern Make
Some Noise if you're not so more have
that concern so on the same sentiments
as you interesting let me ask you a
question Pat I mean I I guess I could
ask you to everyone here what would you
say is desantis's biggest downside right
we can all pick apart Trump's biggest
downside but what would desantis's
biggest downside would be I think I
don't want to speak for the mayor but I
think what you would say is he hasn't
done it before and this job is so big
that it can eat anybody alive but let's
not forget it kind of ate Trump alive
too and again I voted for him and
supported him he kept fauci the entire
time uh there's a you know he ended up
fighting and firing that's the question
so so what would you say what would you
say okay here's what I would say I think
the Santas and his Camp need to come
together at his house or the office and
sit down and watch the documentary of
Roger Ailes that's called divide and
conquer and see how a 25-26 year old
Roger Ailes helped a Nixon who was a
brilliant operator but was not good on
camera become a marketer so he can get
elected because the ills on understood
marketing Nixon did not Nixon wasn't a
marketable product he was not Charming
he was not charismatic Nixon helped with
McConnell Nixon help with Hannity
O'Reilly all of these guys not Nixon I'm
sorry ales you need an else in your life
right everybody needs an else in their
life that's my first campaign there you
go Roger one of my best friend and I was
his lawyer how great manager was he was
a 40 million dollar deal with Fox which
is one of the reasons Fox hates me
because they only wanted to give him 20
million uh so I I know Roger was a very
close but hear me out on what I'm saying
this is the point I'm making so I think
I think
first of all man I'm gonna upset a lot
of people the chances of me ever
interviewing the census and him coming
to our podcast every day goes lower and
lower and lower the more I say what I
say he'll come to you and you can ask a
question that I say and then you can
post it it's a good word for it yeah I
mean but let me tell you let me tell you
what my concern is here's Michael my
call out instead of following who the
hell is on his marketing team
why the hell do you come out with his
book in February knowing you can't
launch till July and the book drops out
of 100 ranking on Amazon one month later
what the hell are you thinking if you
know you can't run till July you don't
launch a book till June what are you
doing launching a book in February do it
in late may do it in June and then go on
a ton of podcasts go on a ton of shows
make sure your book is number one you're
being too tough on it I'm not I can be
talking no no no no wait a minute let me
see the first time candidate the first
time candidates make mistakes but no
it's not about I'm not calling him out I
didn't call him out I'm calling his
marketing team out my conversation is to
the marketing team this is not a call
out to him I think he's a phenomenal
candidate I think he's crushed it we're
in Florida because of him when we were
in Dallas and I'm getting ready to go
through the process of selling the
insurance company my wife and I in the
family sat down and we looked at moving
back to Newport Beach Newsom eliminated
that decision like this we were looking
at moving to Greenwich because we're
starting a media company and I might try
to be in New York to compete with these
guys we're looking at Nashville I lived
in Nashville for a couple years right
outside of it we're looking at Tampa
we're looking at Fort Lauderdale we're
looking at Miami we're looking at
Manalapan or we're looking at staying in
Dallas where Dallas was eliminated
Greenwich was eliminated because the way
they were handling covet Nashville we
like to water the beach is not that good
in Nashville we like to Beach
yeah so we decided on Florida because of
the santis yeah so this is not a message
I'm giving it's the criticism to the
marketing campaign I went and talked to
one of the biggest churches in town I
want to name the person
they came and we started working with
these guys I sat with their marketing
team and I said can I just talk to your
marketing team directly and give me the
pressure uh permission to call them out
and let them be pissed off at me not you
he says go for it I said you're dealing
in a time right now where parents are
frightened to send them to public school
because their kids are coming home
saying mom a guy I got a call on a Mach
7 this week saying a guy was holding one
of our guys's hands in a private school
in Dallas saying hey I like you I'm gay
this kid is 10 years old 12 years old
flirting with this other guy the mom
doesn't know how to handle it she's
worried she's afraid what does she do
about it so many parents right now are
frighten my word to send their kids
transgender well this kid's transgender
how about you have you thought about
having this are you sure you're straight
is it only this have you thought about
having to say all this confusion that
you have churches should be packed right
now every Church in America should be
packed right now what the hell are the
marketing teams that these churches
doing so my call is not a call out to
the Past pastors my call is a call out
to the marketing team of the descentes
campaign that's all it is not wrong it's
the marketing team well actually I think
first off I will gladly I'm sure you
guys have reached out in every possible
way but I will gladly try to get that up
the chain that's just one thing because
you should sit down here stay away from
DVD no they won't but think about it
you're what you're watching you know you
did oh stay away from beauty because
your scare marketing team not Ron you
are they're holding up you're known as
as Fair as possible so I I don't know
what's going on there but putting that
aside for a second you what your
criticism of which is totally legit you
have a very solvable problem right what
you just laid out there was a very
solvable problem terrible timing on the
book you could even see you could be the
guy to sit down with him and say hey
this is what the problem is and I can
actually help you solve for that he
doesn't trust a lot of people which you
can't blame that that may be but in
essence you're giving I asked you for
the biggest criticism and your criticism
which I'm not arguing with is actually
very solvable like you can yes so so
that doesn't seem that deep not not that
deep it doesn't seem hey how do you
problem and you only do a couple shows
thinking the book is going to sell on
its own well I think it was number one
New York Times for that long but that
the whole thing two weeks yeah that
shouldn't be the case with the number
one governor in America that had a state
that everybody wanted to move to that
should not be the I read the whole book
that should not be the case and if you
read the book you will see how many
times you gave credit to Trump in the
book yeah a lot of people on New York
Times or somebody wrote an op-ed saying
the fact that he never gave he took
shots at Trump there was no shots at
Trump he kept giving credit if it wasn't
for the Tweet if it wasn't for this if
it wasn't for that that book was
marketed in the shittiest way possible
again I'm okay being the target yeah all
I'm saying is the marketing team
deserves the criticism sure I'll also
say this having launched my second book
just a couple months before that I mean
I fired basically everyone I worked with
book the book industry is so old and
broken
I'm not saying that's anything I can't
blame the book I'm the with Simon and
Schuster and pink one here's what I said
to them the other day we have a call
Mario if Mario is somewhere around here
is on he remembers when he was on the
call Mario somewhere around here they
said well we think this should be the
title
I said okay cool you want that as a
title of any we can hear you want that
as a title yes okay oh we think this
should be the title I said can I just
pause and ask a question yes
if you guys plan on selling the [__] out
of this pick the title go for it
but if you want me to sell the book I
want this title
and you see everybody's faces this is a
pretty heavyweight guy I got a lot of
respect for you I love this guy matter
he's a stud of a guy he says
well you know what why don't you pick
the title I said no [__] I want to pick
the time because you want me to shoot
the book you don't sell a book nowadays
asking the publisher to sell your book
They're not marketers no they do nothing
so again marketing team change your
strategy you got watch the Roger L's
documentary divide and conquer tonight
great it's a solvable problem yeah by
the way he made me watch that
documentary amazing amazing documentary
go watch that tonight uh when you get
home guys
um but I feel like there's you have a
product and you have marketing we talked
about this Natalia will know this
I would much rather have a marketing
problem than a product problem because
if you have a shitty product
what the hell are you marketing okay but
if you have a great product I.E Ron
DeSantis you can clean up the marketing
so say what you want about Trump he does
not have a marketing problem the problem
is kind of the product
but the scientists in my opinion I think
is a great product but he needs to
re-look you know I I think that was a
very uh irresponsible comment about him
not being his being a great not being a
great product
uh he was probably
[Applause]
he's probably the best president we've
had in 50 years
so when DeSantis can be the best
president for four years I'll agree with
you but he had Santa's hasn't been in
the white house he was not a
particularly effective congressman
he was a terrible candidate when he ran
the first time for office
uh and by the way
let me finish
you can't separate the product and the
marketing that's [__]
that's lack of leadership
I never separated from my team
I'm responsible for my marketing I'm
responsible for my press secretary I'm
responsible for my Administration if I
did that I would have been a lousy mayor
so if you're telling me that you want to
do a separation of well let's blame the
marketing but not the guy who's in
charge Ron DeSantis you don't have a
leader
you got a follower the marketing team is
running everything of course he's
responsible for his marketing he's
responsible for everything that happened
to the damn campaign and if he's not he
shouldn't be president we don't know if
he is like that I I honestly
I I I I think it's more important that
we keep Democrats out of the White House
than any of these guys
then to scientists and Trump then Cruz
or I'd be willing to consider somebody
else if they had a better chance of
saving this country RFK Robert uh no
he's I know RFK for years he sued me
more than anybody else
and I love his book but the rest of them
is awful space in Mars somewhere did you
ever listen to some of the things that
he says I mean
great guy but whoa
so no he she can't be president my God
uh
wow that would be scary but in any event
we
Ron DeSantis right now
is an ephemeral
something
it's a year and a half before the
election he's not really campaigned as
you pointed out that's his
responsibility not his marketing team
unless his marketing team is running
things
right if uh if I don't like
I run my campaign Roger Ailes with my
campaign manager I still ran my campaign
I didn't blame when something went wrong
I didn't blame it on Roger rails I I
don't think that's Ron's personality
though I see Ron as a leader I see Iran
as an executive I see Rana somebody like
Ron I see Ron as a person who was a
great project manager what happened on
Ukraine I think he's such a leader why
the hell did he sort of change his
position on Ukraine he's got three
different positions on Ukraine but that
part Rudy I would say I don't know so so
uh he becomes an isolationist to suck up
to Tucker Carlson and then he becomes a
a a a Reagan Republican so you'll call
him a flip-flopper is what you're oh I'm
saying it's a dangerous tendency don't
go uh don't you know politics is not a
game of love at first sight
you don't get to know somebody he could
be a great candidate he may not be you
don't know that he shows some very good
Tendencies and he shows some very big
weaknesses that's flipping around on
Ukraine was very dangerous so flip-flop
is what you're saying that's the word
one time you're an immigrant but in
English language let's see if that's uh
him yeah well let's see if that was a
mistake I'm willing to say he's a new
time candidate
uh we don't know we do not know how he's
going to Bear up
under running for governor of of Florida
and running for president United States
yeah it's like running for school
president and then running for a major
role I don't think there's any dispute
there I I don't I wouldn't disagree with
you there but I would also tell you I've
seen people who were great candidates
Statewide who totally fall apart as
presidential candidates
and I'm not going to say he will but
he's I'd be careful betting the whole
thing on him because he's shown some
Tendencies some weaknesses
if they are really weaknesses that will
he won't be there at the end as many
Front Runners went out there at the end
so I'm not even sure he'll eventually be
uh Trump's major opposition I can tell
you Trump will be there at the end he
owns 40 of the party
you also got to be careful how bad you
go after him because then you won't be
able to win
you've got to run as a as a candidate
running against it
yeah it's great to bring new people in a
bit of a fantasy also
the only person that's been able to
bring a lot of new only two people have
brought a lot of new people into
politics since Reagan
Obama
Andre and Trump trump won the first time
with new people
so
we got a few people here so I don't know
if that who was the first Clapper
who was the first Clapper can you okay
where are you I'm not sure I'm not sure
you win elections when I when I ran for
office which is which is ages ago you
won by going to the middle
there were the Liberals the
conservatives and then there was the
middle and I won uh being mayor of New
York by going to the middle I had a
winner in a democratic State I don't
know if you can win that way anymore I
don't know if there's enough of a middle
I'm not sure you might be able to but
I'm not sure that going to the middle
you lose your base
and here's what I always advise Trump
I don't care what CNN says about you I
don't care what MSNBC says about you I
don't care what the Liberals say about
you it's not going to hurt you
when I start seeing your base turn then
we start to worry
because you can't exist in politics
without a solid base any longer that's
what that's what Biden has for sick
reasons and that's what Trump has and
that's why
they may be the two most dangerous
candidates you you may you may only be
able to win Now by appealing to your
base and bringing them out more than the
other guys or just plain cheating
that's another way to win
yeah and don't discount that Mr Meyer
um we've asked this question repeatedly
but I would love to get your take on
this but is there any chance that you
see if Trump gets the nominee him uh
pinning
Governor DeSantis as his running mate he
can't they're both in the same state one
of them would have to move out of
Florida
you uh a president and vice president
can't run if they're residents of the
same state Kate page 793 you didn't read
that
600 Pat I'll do better but I don't know
I don't know that either one of them
would be the right vice president but if
he could if he'd like let's say he
really wanted him and Trump re-domiciled
to New York let's just say it would
depend it would depend a little on on
the primary and how how strong uh Kamala
Harris started the Democratic primary
looking Invincible right she beat The
Living Daylights out of Biden in the
first debate by the second debate Tulsi
gabbard had totally ripped her apart and
uh proved that she's one of the silliest
people ever in American politics so what
do you think Dave it would depend on how
good a candidate is well it's
interesting because if I'm getting this
right the two biggest criticisms of
DeSantis seemed to be that he had a
shoddy book launch which okay let's say
that's that's kind of right which again
got to number one on New York Times
bestseller as as much [__] as that
thing is uh you can tell that they left
my last book off the list
um
but so he so he okay he screwed up a
book launch let's say and let's just say
everyone in this room agrees with that
and that he hasn't been president before
well most presidents haven't been
president before and I don't know that
you can blame the guy for a book launch
so I haven't heard any real criticism of
the guy right I did say about the
Ukraine flips okay so all right that
that I would count as a criticism a
little bit of a flip of slipping on a
very important subject that you should
be prepared for if you are a
presidential candidate not as bad as uh
Ted Kennedy uh not knowing why he's
running for president I mean that was
but was your point
there's nothing here I could feel it in
the room there's there's not much no
one's going oh he's got this policy that
really screwed us he's wrong on the
schools he's wrong on ESPN but you're
running him against a you're running
against a guy who actually did it
already
but you're running against the guy
you're you're gambling a teeny bit let's
say you're gambling a teeny bit when you
don't have to gamble at all you you know
that Trump will straighten out the
economy but but Trump
lost the last election I don't think he
lost the last election but okay so we go
yeah here we go
Rudy I will I'll go further than that
if you want to come to my house and go
into my study I'll show you a thousand
affidavits to prove it Rudy there'll be
2 000 people in front of your house
tomorrow
he's joking folks I'm not joking he's
joking they're gonna google your address
Rudy open the door Rudy
he did not lose
the the the the the
one o'clock in the morning when I left
the White House on Election night into
the next day he was ahead in
Pennsylvania by 750 000 votes it is
statistically impossible
for him to have lost Pennsylvania now
you go watch the movie uh 2 000 mules if
you want
you can watch three or four other movies
you could watch the older documentary
about uh the the the machines to be used
that were tested before the election and
the Democrats objected to them
Dominion right uh isn't there a lawsuit
right now still pending with the
Dominion and and what's the number
they're going after is it Fox 1.6
billion or whatever whatever the number
you're hearing about yeah that's a Dodge
that that's a that's being done
uh to try to frighten people into going
after them that's not that's not a
that actually it's a great tactic by his
lawyers you can't you can't do a prior
restraint under American law you can't
go in and stop somebody from speaking
but you can intimidate them into not
speaking and that's what that lawsuit is
all about it has uh it has made even
stations like Fox and Newsmax like we're
not going to mention Dominion we're not
going to mention Dominion brilliant
strategy by the lawyer unethical as hell
but a brilliant strategy by the lawyers
we're not going to do it
um but I I I'm telling you he did not
lose the last election but even though
he even though he should have because
everything was stacked against him
and not only that the hard drive
was suppressed
and American people never never knew 90
of what was in there on purpose
uh so but but Rudy I would say this to
you dirty politics is nothing new okay
that is nothing new it's going to be
here it's not going away okay that that
is not going to be to to sit there and
say well that's why he lost well then
they're gonna do it again and again yeah
but but no no all I'm saying to you is
Nick they won't cheat against the
sadness the Santa's will get nominated
and the Democrats will say oh we'll give
it to him yes we can cheat we we we we
own Pennsylvania
we would cheat in Philadelphia just for
practice
and we're not going to cheat against
DeSantis he's going to have the same
problem in fact he's going to become a
very polarizing figure if he continues
to maintain the positions he has as
Governor you see but but nationally but
I was a very I'll give you the criticism
I'll give you the criticism they get
here's the criticism though the
criticism is if the campaign is they
cheated
believe it or not that's not the camera
hang on a second let me just give you my
point of view why I think that's a bad
approach or even to even talk about it
why let me give you my perspective you
can push back all you want when you say
something like that you know what it
does here's the [__] conversation I
hear that's very annoying you know what
the conversation is well why vote
anyways they're going to cheat why would
I vote the more you say that that's not
a good strategy in my opinion the more
you don't say it you suppress no no and
they continue to do it no no
in order to solve a problem you have to
face it if you suppress if you if you
accept their unbelievable Distortion of
our system by cheating in an election
you might as well give up this country
say that all you want nobody's
disagreeing with you and sitting there
saying that's not like weaponizing or
doing all the stuff that they're doing
fine they're doing it you still have to
beat them of course you still have I
didn't say I didn't say we shouldn't
beat them what I'm telling you is I'm
not going to go around and say to people
something that I know is untrue you
can't say they're gonna cheat and then
say well go out there and vote because
when you say they're going to cheat and
you got to say listen guys we don't know
what's going to happen let's assume the
words here's what's important get
everybody to go your mom your dad your
your dish your auntie get everybody to
show up we don't know if it's gonna
happen my product if when you're
competing as in the in the free
Marketplace you know my guys will have a
room and they'll say well Patrick let me
tell you that office they do this and
they refinance and cash out and put
money in variable annuities and but they
we can't beat those guys I'm like dude
don't even bring that I'll say you can't
beat them what I said they cheated in
the last election I didn't say you can't
beat them but it and it's it's very very
different to cheat in marketing and to
fix an election in the Democratic
country I mean that is a that's a
massive so so and if you let people do
it if you stay quiet about it it becomes
the norm
you've got to raise it you've got to
urge your people to work harder you've
got to urge your people to get out and
get get up off their backsides and vote
you've got to get Republicans to change
their pattern of voting just on Election
Day and in states that have this you
know
okay so then talk about that okay for
example so
approach okay approach you ever see guys
like we're watching who was fighting
Usman was fighting cool when he lost the
first time who was Usman fighting when
uh uh who was it
Edwards remember the first fight you're
like oh this thing's over with we're
sitting in the house we're watching this
this fight is over with minute 10
seconds left what does Usman do who saw
that fight he kept backing up backing up
backing up boom kick comes look how the
hell did this just happen meaning a
strategy that worked for Trump to win
you can't go away from that strategy his
strategy was policies we're going to
make America great again we're going to
build a border we're going to do this
that's what he's doing that's what he
just did the last speech I I agree the
speech but if it's gonna if the strategy
is going to be you know let us say it's
unfair let let the people say it's
unfair what they're doing let everybody
else say it's on for what they're doing
let us be the flag carrier I don't think
that can come out to say well you know
they did this to me and they did that to
me I don't know if that's how you want
it I think the the the uh Democrat uh
strategy has worked on you which is to
intimidate us into raising the fact that
they cheated in the last election well
over 55 percent of the American people
maybe up to 60 believe that they cheated
in the last election I think 100 of
people believe cheating is going on so
so uh you know how many guys believe
they're cheating every single time in
every election I don't think it's 55 I
think it's 100 I didn't say cheating in
every election I said cheating in that
election to win there's no reason not to
one other reason would somebody cheat or
you cheat to win I think it's done every
single time but you don't always win
when you cheat well you guys you cheat
and you don't win but but it doesn't
mean that it's not a tactic that's been
used like it just started two years but
it's a tactic that you have to end you
can't tolerate it I would say what has
he done to end it let's say we all every
single forget the sentence let's say the
Santa's like I want to I'm just gonna
move to the Everglades that's it I'm out
so now Trump so now Trump is the nominee
for sure and and virtually everyone in
this room is willing to support the guy
what has he done in uh Pennsylvania what
has he done in Arizona what has he done
in these swing States aids to fix any of
that because otherwise it will be
election night 20 24 and he'll be
leading in those last seven states just
like last time I was I was on air with
the daily wire guys that night on
Election night I left early because it
was so obvious that Trump was going to
win and I wanted to get home so they
will do the same damn thing because
nobody's done anything what has anyone
done in Pennsylvania or or I watched 2
000 mules I like Dinesh it's like all
right what's going to stop this again
here's what will stop it again and
there's been some progress made not
complete so Georgia Wisconsin even with
the new Supreme Court the Republicans
want every other race in Wisconsin that
was a function of of uh of uh the
abortion issue with the Republican
landslide in Wisconsin and the
Republican Justice lost and the
Democratic Justice won so they got a
Liberal Liberal court and that became
the news actually Wisconsin was a big
Republican Landslide they got a super
majority in both houses of the
legislature we Wisconsin passed a law so
you can't do and we'll go into detail
you can't do in this election what you
did in the last election which is a
massive number of of mail-in ballots
they restricted significantly mail-in
ballots Georgia passed the law uh that
will seriously restrict the ability to
do that those are two states where
you'll probably get an honest count this
time uh
Pennsylvania you couldn't pass the law
because the Democrats control the both
houses of the legislature and you
haven't yet you had a crooked Governor
you haven't you have another crooked
governor and uh he was part of the
cheating in the first place so
Pennsylvania you're going to have to do
volunteers you're going to have to do uh
voter Integrity efforts the first
election that I ran for mayor I lost by
half a percent
and I had a well over fifty thousand uh
uh questionable votes I lost by thirty
thousand and I decided not to contest it
I was young I was a new candidate as the
first Republican to get 48 percent since
fiorella LaGuardia in the city that
Abraham Lincoln lost twice let me give
you an idea how Democratic it is and
everyone said well this is almost like a
victory it's nice for them to say that
when you lose but you could have a great
future in politics getting up to 48 and
I lost to the first black mayor of New
York if I had contested that election my
political career would be over
I honestly believe they cheated I mean
it's a different kind of cheating they
would uh pay people to vote 10 times
and you that's why you keep the dead
people on the voting list you keep them
there because the party uh operative in
that district has all their names and
then you pay people Philadelphia is
famous for this you pay you pay people
to vote 10 12 times that day using dead
people and people that moved out and
they don't allow you to purge the voting
list you go before a democratic court
and the judge doesn't allow you to do
that that can happen again in
Pennsylvania unless we triple the number
of volunteers that we have and we do
very very strong voter Integrity so the
second time I ran I invested a million
dollars in a voter Integrity effort and
my my campaign inspectors or correction
officers and firefighters
because they're scared of correction
officers and firefighters and they're
tough guys and you're not going to screw
around on them and when the bus would
show up with the people voting the third
and the fourth time they'd see the true
firefighters outside some of them had
their pitchforks with them you know and
that bus will turn around
people who ran it for me was the present
president of the Yankees and a guy who's
now in the United States Congress I got
two really tough brilliant people to run
the effort for me and they say we still
gave away about 20 000 votes but we won
by 60. but they still cheated in that
election it's impossible for Democrats
in a big city not to cheat even if
they're going to win for sure or lose
for sure uh so we partially solved the
problem we partially didn't and what I'm
telling you applies to any Republican
not just Trump not just the Santa's this
is something Trump's going to have to do
if he gets the nomination it's something
to Sanders is going to have to do if he
gets the nomination
uh and he's gonna have to hope
that because they did it last time and
because it gets raised a lot it's gonna
it's gonna stop some of it it's going to
scare a few people
maybe yes maybe no but you got to have
an energized group of volunteers who go
to the polls stay at the polls insist on
seeing the identifications of every
voter uh repo we didn't have that in 20
20. partially a function of not
realizing they were going to cheat that
much or not accepting it and partially a
function of of the pandemic Mr Mayor can
I ask you a question this is probably
the one question I wanted to ask you
um so this is a question on your legacy
if you don't mind yeah let's stay on
this no no I want to wrap this up this
is regarding this you you you're not
going to go to like what are the seven
keys to success
but I'm just gonna
go back and then I'm going to go forward
here we go I'm going to go back to 2001
everyone knows what happened 911
you were America's mayor I was a senior
in college we all remember everything on
this topic yes I'm staying on this topic
sir if he doesn't I'm throwing this guys
you were America's mayor you were
beloved Beyond okay it wasn't a
democratic thing Republican thing 20
years later because everything you're
saying now whether you're right or wrong
election denialism cheaters Crooks all
that everything you're saying
um some may say that your legacy has
been tarnished that's what people say
um but a lot of it is because of I'll
catch up then
a lot may say because of the election
denialism is this a hill you're willing
to die on do you care that much about
this that it may or may not ruin your
legacy all I care about is if I can be
honest with myself
I don't give a goddamn what my legacy
I I know
when I told you the election was stolen
I know it was stolen I don't just think
it was I investigated it
uh I've got the documents I've got the
proof in the in the seven key States I
can tell you by how much he probably won
each state
and uh yeah I'll die with it so why
hasn't it been proven okay guys because
because
of censorship let me let me let me it's
not been proven because nobody will
allow you to prove it the courts punked
out probably John Roberts said we're
going to stay out of this and we're
going to use uh technical excuses not to
hear a single freaking Witness
half the Republican Party ran away
because they're a bunch of cowards
and wouldn't wouldn't stand up to the
press that was beating The Living
Daylights out of them and most people
don't want to get disbarred like I was
most of the people don't want to be
driven into bankruptcy which they try to
do
and most people can't stand up when
they're doing the right thing but they
get viciously attacked for it and
they're cowards and they back down
[Music]
and I uh and I I never I never cared
about my I don't really give a damn
about my life can I can I say I know
what I did mayor let me say something I
know what I'm doing and in a different
world in a different world yeah in a
different world you want to throw the
pen out how are you going to throw the
pen at everybody at this point from this
by the way if the audience was Armenian
they would throw a two-stage they're
sandals okay so but let me let me say
this part okay I got four kids so my kid
comes and he loses and he says the other
team cheated
okay and I say you're right they did
cheat
okay as a parent if I take that angle
they did cheat that kid is going to use
that as an alibi for the rest of his
life I'm sorry I have a hard time
totally different things
let me make my argument to you and tear
it apart say whatever you want let me
tear it apart let me just make an
argument for you let me let me make my
argument to you
let me give you a perspective by the way
that's totally fine I'm a big boy I can
take it FYI you lost
you lost
you ever seen the movie Tropic Thunder
we lost we lost I don't know if you've
seen it you don't look like a Tropic
Thunder Thai but don't worry about it so
watch this okay football sports
so you're talking about you got barred
okay you lost your license no I didn't
suspended suspended fine suspended is
what you got which by the way a lot of
you know there's a lot of different that
that is a history of a lot of different
people that lost their licenses yours is
using abuse they took advantage of what
they're doing which is not cool what
they did to you so I'm on that page
which what happened there but in sports
so uh uh who's the quarterback with the
Baltimore Ravens what's the guy's name
uh oh no no who's the guy from Arizona
the guy from Arizona that came out
what's the guys from Arizona Murray
right and he gets hurt he comes back RG3
says don't come back if I was you I
would stay out he comes back he gets
hurt he's out boom they don't go to the
playoffs nothing's gonna happen without
that guy okay RG3 comes back even though
he should have stayed out the season he
comes back career ending probably cost
him a couple hundred million dollars
okay he was a great quarterback okay
mayor
you being injured is hurting the camp
because they needed a fighter like you
so we lost a player that was a fighter
that can be competing today in the
marketplace so for me what I'm saying is
it's very easy for us to play this game
while we're getting hurt and losing
versus sitting there and figuring out a
different kind of strategy to be because
we can give all the motivational
speeches and sound right and people can
clap and it can sound very good and
exciting and we can lose 2024 again or
we can take a different approach to say
look guys
what do you believe it happened or not I
think it did let's just say whether you
believe it happened or not fine this is
where I'm at this is my position however
we can't sit here and go back and hey
Houston Astros cheated and they won't
but I think but I think we are a little
bit Houston Houston Astros came back and
even after cheating they still won again
but you're missing you're you're
misdescribing what I said I have not
said that should be our strategy to get
elected I'm not stupid
it is something that we have to affirm
and be honest about and open about so we
change it we can't buy into the Democrat
[__] which is it didn't happen so
they can do it again I don't think
people are buying it to that I don't
think people are buying and the only way
you can show that it's gonna it's gonna
remain on the agenda is by standing up
to it you don't have to run it would be
ridiculous to run on it you should run
on on what I think we need to see you're
talking about it but stop talking about
it and running on it or two two
different things if you stop talking
about it you've accomplished what the
Democrats want so you know what picture
is the censor you so you would restrict
your free speech to not allow you to say
what you think is important you look
like a guy you're you're you look like a
guy there you like good memes you like a
good you have a good meme game
I don't even know what you're talking
about
okay I saw meme the other day okay you
know what I'm can anybody tell him what
a meme is what's a meme meme is what
it's like one of these pictures they
post and then they you know it's funny
cartoon funny cartoon but they post
these memes anyways so I saw meme the
other day you know what it said I loved
it it says you should have drained the
swamp when you had the chance to and you
didn't
he didn't drain the swamp there was a
part of the campaign that we voted for
was to eliminate those games and it
didn't happen now you may say well they
got in his way and they did this and
they did that fine no problem we voted
for during the swamp and those guys are
still there
and if you're gonna go and run a new
company and there's a bunch of Schmucks
running a company that are running the
old model fire them and replace them who
says he's not going to do that and why
wouldn't he why wouldn't he be the best
person to do it because he knows it
better than anybody else knows he's
motivated to do it because they they he
realizes what actually happened to
America and to play the game of pretend
is a terrible terrible mistake well the
other option and to play the game of of
having them dictate what you say and
what you don't say eventually it gets us
where we are today a country where free
speech is restricted more than a lot of
totalitarian governments that would be a
terrible thing if we don't insist on
maintaining what we know we shouldn't
run on it we should run on how we can
fix the economy or the standards can fix
the economy or somebody else we agree
how we can bring peace how we can bring
how we had a much more peaceful world
when we had a republican in office how
uh how in fact we had uh
trade agreements that were much more
favorable Kim yong-un wasn't flying
missiles over Japan China was uh
somewhat a lot more contained and Russia
didn't take Ukraine while we had a
republican in the white house and we can
go back to that that's what we should
run on nobody wants to run on the
election was stolen but if you asked me
if it was
I'm going to tell you it was straight
out the honest truth
we don't do that then we lose something
that Trump did for us he made us value a
candidate who can be honest with us who
can tell us the truth one thing about
Trump was that was never a hidden agenda
he was maybe too open
but boy we need that we don't need a
political game player the last thing in
the world this country needs is a
political game player we're in too much
trouble we've already become a socialist
country
we gotta we don't have to stop us from
being a socialist country we don't have
to prevent the change in our way of life
it's happened
we have to take it back we're not taking
it back by playing sorry Patrick
marketing games we've got to do it for
real and we need a real person as a
candidate not a creation of Madison
Avenue
say that to any major organization who's
been an incredible marketer including 45
who is a master master marketer Dave
well perhaps we should all support a guy
who could become a Transcendent
reagan-like candidate who's younger who
is an incredibly Ultra competent
executive who none of us can find
someone Newsom you're saying who none of
us
seemingly our worst flaw with him is
that he had a slightly botched book
campaign that got to number one on the
New York Times maybe we actually
overwhelmed the system
more people that I think okay can we
transition into something a little bit
more important like getting you guys to
be sponsored by Nike or Bud Light or
some of the other things okay can we can
we put this out there please I want to
help you get sponsored by Nike there's a
strategy on how I don't know if you've
been following the story
no no it's actually by the way if you
did it um how many guys think they want
to follow the strategy he could be the
mayor could be sponsored by Nike yes or
no before we show the story some of you
guys know what I'm talking about let's
put the story out here what you're
talking about listen I'm going to give
you a strata you don't have to use it
I'm just telling you there is a Playbook
on how to do it there's this person I
want to hear it let's talk about it if
you want to put the picture up right now
trans women
and new Bud Light partner Dylan Mulvaney
now paid by Nike to model sports sports
bras okay on top of that by the way by
the way not only sports bras
Bud Light did you guys see the Bud Light
Video going viral and all this stuff did
you guys see him dancing with the whole
you know the Nike sports bra stuff and
then you got Kate Spade you got Ultra
Beauty you got a Crest toothpaste and
according to Newsweek which we may be
wrong but according to Newsweek if you
can pull this story up according to
Newsweek which this one this is not
Babylon B this is not onion according to
Newsweek he's about to be sponsored by
Tampax he is and apparently based on
this this Mulvaney guy According to some
of the Articles you read about which is
kind of deeply concerning he's not fully
committed he's not a True Believer
because he still has a dangling which
which kind of makes it a little bit
complicated because he's not fully gone
there okay do you realize that every
single day on my show and my team is
sitting right there I have to live on
air say the same thing could you guys
Google it does she have a dick and
the fact that I just said that in front
of Rudy Giuliani
[Applause]
I lived in New York City during 9 11
like this guy is a true hero and I
apologize for even doing that I don't
know what a meme is but I know what a
dick is
[Music]
ladies don't worry thank you good night
oh my God
you let this descend to this bill
you thought you were going to lighten
the mood a little bit there pat pat
visit you realize you realize this is
where you were supposed to pull out a
big machete
the desk and say which one of you look I
just thinking why do you say that on
everything because every news
every news story these days is about a
former man now dressed as a woman and
we're always trying to figure out have
they gone the full way so for example
Rachel Levine who was a dude dick Levine
which is hilarious Rachel Levine was
Dick Levine you know that yeah wow yeah
his name was appropriate his name was
Dick he guys correct me wrong he still
has a dick yeah he still has a dick yeah
how do we but how do we know that how do
we know
I'm just kidding don't put the picture
but every day there is another one of
these ridiculous stories where one of
these guys dressing as a girl and then
so it always to me it's like if you're
gonna actually you know Caitlyn Jenner
went all the way supposedly Caitlyn
Jenner no Wang really yeah wow
that's all good for her I don't know but
it's not to feel pains yeah so the fact
that this keeps happening over and over
oh you know you know what's crazy as
much as obviously we're joking about
this there's a part of this that's funny
and we're having a lot you know enjoying
this part there's a part of it that
parents are sitting there saying what
the hell are we doing like how the hell
is this argument even creating momentum
where it's being defended by the media
and how dare you say such a thing about
them why shouldn't they have the rights
and all this other stuff and your I saw
a meme the other day okay I know you're
again going back to memes can you just
show him a meme so we can please show me
a dick
hey you know what I want you to do Rob
do me a favor and go to pbd podcast
Twitter account you are so we didn't
know you were a comedian mayor Giuliani
today comedy side so go to pbd podcast
Twitter account and I'm gonna text this
to you if you go on Twitter go to pbd
podcast I'll text the student go find
this wonderful meme it's not that I want
keep going over there it's not that one
keep going it's the one that says can
you drive a car can you do this it's a
day ago if you can find I just texted it
to you there you go watch this one here
okay can you drive a car no can you pick
your bedtime no can you drink a beer no
can you vote no can you cut off sex
organs and take hormones yes
oh my God
I mean this is common sense stuff as
much as we're having you know we're
having fun with this this Mulvaney guy I
have a hard time saying this first time
because my son is his name it's a
wonderful name it's kind of confusing me
a little bit so you hear him sitting
down with you know Drew Barrymore and
she gets on her knees which is kind of
like a little you know weird situation
there but parents are worried it's
concerning okay they should be did you
for a guy like it did you ever think
we're gonna get to a point like this
where people who kept their dangling are
going out there promoting about the fact
that they're on the other side no I I I
didn't there was a candidate for
governor of uh North Carolina oh about
10 12 years ago so this goes way back
McCrory is a great Governor 60 approval
rating running for re-election and the
issue came up about bathrooms you know
they they've the debate was started in
North Carolina about what bathrooms to
go into and he he wasn't his good friend
of mine and I said that's easy you just
do it based on biology well he took that
position he lost by 10 in North Carolina
I mean and that was the beginning of
what the hell's going wrong and what's
going on what is no I don't completely I
have to admit I do not completely
understand what is going on it seems to
me it's obvious there's a man and a
woman we can figure out who's a man and
who's a woman and why we're going
through all this
I don't know if it's a mass psychosis or
it's a deliberate plot to undermine us
maybe it's both you know what politician
actually had the best answer on this
it's Donald Trump before he was even a
politician when he got asked about this
because you're right this happened in
North Carolina and then the NBA was
going to pull out an All-Star Game and
this whole thing and they asked Trump
when he was still just Celebrity
Apprentice Trump they said what do you
think about these trans bathrooms he
goes I'm a builder I build hotels you
tell me I can build one bathroom I'm
Gonna Save on construction
yeah
hahaha
okay
there you go so Dave Chappelle has an
amazing joke uh uh on the LGBT have you
heard this thing on the closer it's like
they're all on a car ride together and
you get the G the G's driving because
that's the white guy it's a guy the G
the L's sitting shotgun right and
everyone loves the elves but except for
the G's because they're all they're kind
of like I wouldn't wear that whatever
then you have the bees
you follow me here Rudy oh you're so far
you're gonna get the B and the bees in
the back just basically like oh [__]
anyone in this car I don't care right
and then you got the T and the t is kind
of like making the whole ride go way
longer than it should it take for the
G's the B's the L's because the t is not
anything like a g or an lrp it's
completely different and there's all
different parts going on different ways
so as a g yeah you you're you're not
anything close to T well first off we
just use like 20 of the album I'm only
gay starting at 10 pm what time is it
it's 9 30. Rudy immediately checked his
watch we'll see about that
laughs
look I
I did a gay wedding I mean you know
you lived you lived with two gay guys I
did I did absolutely that's more that's
one more game guys
wonderful parents they're still married
and parents but what happens
I signed the first domestic partnership
bill in 1994. I've never I've never I've
always seen it as a question of Human
Rights and uh
uh I get I guess I'm you know to a large
extent a Libertarian uh
except I realized the need for laws
because we got some really evil and
dangerous people uh by the way like
people Live and Let Live if if mayor
would have ran in 2016 on his policies
that he had when he had ran for
president he's not a mayor he would be a
president today just so everybody knows
the the things you ran on 20 years ago I
may get the dates wrong whatever the
date was when you ran as president
everybody thought you were going to win
some of this stuff was 15 years ahead of
your time you had some libertarian side
America wasn't ready for it absolutely
five years ago you'd be a president in
America if you would have those policies
timing is the key in politics this is
why I said you should have identified us
it just needs to run now you're right I
mean I'd like to disagree with that
because I I am committed to Trump but I
agree with you he um
there may not be another time
there may not be you think well okay
he's a great governor
he'll continue to be a great Governor I
imagine that's true I can't see why he
would stop being a great Governor if he
doesn't get nominated but there may be
somebody else that comes along that's
the that's even more impressive or the
flavor of the day or the issues may
change this is the time where but for a
while he was number one now he's number
two
if you're number one two or three that's
your time to run for president and we
can think of a lot of people who missed
their time I could think of one but uh
me but um but no I think Nelson
Rockefeller who could have been
president if he ran it just the right
time I kind of think that Trump would
never be president if he didn't run in
2016.
and that was his time because they had
uh they had alienated people I mean it's
the people I I went to New Palestine uh
you know when the terrible thing
happened there because I saw them as
representative of our people
the people that voted for Trump the
people that voted Republican in 16 the
people who have been uh not taken
seriously the people have been rejected
the people who are called deplorable I
actually saw a little Petey
buddha jug oh man he actually showed up
because I went there and because Trump
went there and we watched him my my uh
colleague Chad and I we watched him
the the mayor who asked me to come and
the police chief let him wait for 45
minutes outside and continue the
conversation with me about the most
irrelevant things I was there to advise
them on how to deal with the crisis
because they wanted to just screw him
you know give him a hard time well when
you want to see him outside he put
himself in a place that he didn't have
to be near any of these people these
dirty people
these dirty hard-working people who
mostly are descendants of coal miners
and they you know they're not dressed
properly and they're not
and that's those are the people who put
Trump in office the people the rejected
people so it may be that that isn't
there right now or it may be there but
he ran it exactly the right time
and uh
I think DeSantis is going to run and I
think
he's good he probably feels this is it I
mean
can we can we can we wrap up with one
last topic here before we finish it off
some may take that as an endorsement for
DeSantis that was a wonderful uh uh
position you took right there uh mayor
Giuliani it's not an endorsement it's a
beautiful political uh it's a beautiful
thing right there but okay so all right
let's let's go through this so let me
give some stats and this this last part
here this is specifically uh directed to
Mayor Eric Adams this is directed to
London breed San Francisco mayor this is
directed to Mayor Brandon Johnson shy
Town Chicago we're going to give you
some statistics and there's a case study
of a guy here who was able to clean up
the streets of New York let me read some
of these studies between 1993 and 2001
New York City experienced a 66 decline
in murders according to FBI okay during
that time you were there during the same
period there was a 72 percent decline in
shootings okay New York City explain
experienced a 50 six percent decline in
FBI crime index 93 to 2001 outpacing 16
decline in National crime index in
addition to the decline in murders New
York side 45.7 decline in rape 67
decline in robberies 39.6 decline in
aggravated assault 68 decline in
burglary 43 decline in larceny 73.3
percent decline in motor vehicle theft
again this is according to FBI in 1993
there was 11
545 Major Crimes per week by 2001 that
number dropped to 5072 over a seven year
period mayor Giuliani added 12 000
police officers in New York City you
took it up to 40
000 you're looking at some of the stats
today on what's going on just yesterday
or two days ago the CEO of cash app uh
who is in San Francisco he's living in
Miami he escaped San Francisco you were
talking about earlier lives in Miami
he's in San Francisco he gets stabbed to
death okay everybody's coming I said
well here's what we're going to be doing
you saw San Francisco said the mayor you
know we are the prioritizing uh Public
Safety you know in San Francisco After
Cash app creators fatal stabbing you
know how uh you know the mayor uh breed
extremely sympathy to the family and
friends of cash out Creator Bob Lee
following his fatal stabbing calling it
a horrible tragedy Tech leaders
including Twitter co-founder Jack Dorsey
and Elon Musk offer condolences on
social media with musk calling for
strong reaction from the city to
incarcerate repeat violence offenders
least friend Jake Shields revealed that
Lee had just moved out of San Francisco
to Miami because he felt the city was
deteriorating while San Francisco
violent crime rate is relatively low
compared to other larger cities again
this is an Insider story this is an
Insider story uh while San Francisco
going through that and then boom the
different numbers that they're going to
have you know what's going on in San
Francisco so if these guys are watching
right now if they're watching right now
how would you today if you are the mayor
of San Francisco if you're the mayor of
Chicago You're the mayor of New York how
are you cleaning up the streets in those
cities
well I mean it's it's a little bit of a
of a of a strange question because their
political
philosophy their political temperament
there is so totally inconsistent with
running a safe City I mean every one of
their policies makes the city more
dangerous
and their allegiance is to the Democrat
Party and its left-wing philosophy not
to the people
I know Adam's the best he works for me
for eight years as a policeman I don't
remember an arrest that he made
and he says the right things people
voted for him in New York because they
thought he was the among the Democrats
one who emphasized war and Order
he says all the right things we should
change our bail laws of course we should
we shouldn't let people out just
yesterday they let out a person they let
out a man who killed his son they let
him out on bail
no bail they just they just let him out
the guys walking around the streets a
day after he killed his son or two days
after he killed his son that's insane
that doesn't just arguable it's just
insane uh the the it's very much a part
of the national Democrat approach to
Crime uh the leader of our state
legislature said the other day you're
never going to reduce crime by
incarcerating people
that's actually the only way to reduce
crime
particularly with career criminals
so uh they they would have to change
their entire first of all they have to
change their party affiliation and every
time Adam says something he doesn't go
through with it because they throw him
out of the Democrat Party if he did uh
he backs off
so this is and this is every city that
has
heavy crime it's a Democrat mayor
very often it's a Soros diet every city
you mentioned is a Soros GA put there to
let criminals out
um for the purpose of creating chaos
in fact all of the DA's that let the
rioters go in 2020
and they're now paying them money
they're actually in New York we've paid
money to people that were arrested in
2020. they're all they all have Soros
DA's as well
and Soros is the biggest contributor of
antifa the biggest contributor black
lives matter the biggest contributor to
the Democratic party the biggest
contributor to Biden and the biggest
contributor to these DA's so it's almost
in it I mean I could
be blue in the face and telling them how
to reduce crime they're not going to do
it uh they they would have to resign and
put a republican there who hopefully
would say let me look at a way it was
done before and repeat it
so you would hire a lot more police
we're down to 33 000 police officers
that's not enough for New York City
they don't prioritize police officers de
Blasio defunded them by a billion
dollars and Adams has never put the
money back a billion dollars taken out
of the police department
what do you think happens uh not only
that even if he wanted to hire police
officers
they're not going to be New York City
police officers all our police officers
Escape if they don't go to Florida they
go to Nassau County Suffolk County or
Suburban counties to pay the police
officers more and treat them with a lot
more respect
so he it'd be you would have to have a
mayor
that created morale in the police
department that the police department
trusted not to
jeopardize their lives in their careers
anytime there was a political
controversy you would have to go back to
deciding on how you enforce the law
based on comstat comstat is a program
that I invented with Bill Bratton
uh it goes back to my days in the
justice department when I handled FBI
statistics with measures crime
and locates it in exactly the places
where it's growing
and you move your police based on
statistics based on
real facts not sentiments political
pressure so uh if all of a sudden you
see
three murders in a particular area
you start to move into that area try to
find out why see if you can find a
common cause you reward your police
officers not just for making arrests but
for reducing crime
and you penalize the commanders when
crime goes up so change incentives yeah
that's one of the things here's what I
thought I did I changed policing
the best policing up until the time I
was mayor is based on how many arrests
you make
I reviewed an arrest as a failure
somebody's already been victimized
somebody's already been killed somebody
been robbed somebody's already been
raped interesting the real goal is
prevent it
so by using the comstat program I could
measure
when you became a commander of a
Precinct how much crime you had each one
of the categories you're talking about
and then how much you're reducing it
or how much it's going up I promoted you
if you reduced it
I put you so far away from where you
lived if it went up that you resigned uh
I'm I manage by uh
rewarding success but I define success
as reducing crime never happens it's
very important by the way so success to
you was reducing crime not increasing
arrests absolutely I mean increase
arrest only for the purpose of reducing
crime what's the second and so what's
the second data you track as success so
first one is how you reduce crime in
your District or in your city then
what's the second one the second one is
you look at the things that are
long-term going to matter like if you
show me an increase in shooting
someplace I can tell you that six months
later you're gonna see an increase in
Murder because it's starting to move
toward violence so work on the shootings
if you start seeing a neighborhood that
had no graffiti
start to have graffiti
you know that that neighborhood is going
to become
overridden by gangs eventually they've
actually started to move in already
so get rid go after the graffiti people
because they're probably also the gang
members
uh one of the things that de Blasio did
that helped to raise crime in New York
this will sound strange as he stopped
arresting the people who were Fair
beaters on the subway
we arrested everybody who was a fair
beater never had been done before turned
out that 45 of the people will be
arrested were dangerous criminals who
were wanted
so we got them we also solved a Serial
murder that way because a guy who had
never been arrested had killed two women
he was on his way to probably killing 10
or 15.
he did a
turnstile jump we arrested him we
fingerprinted him we never would have
fingerprinted him if he had an arrest
him and then his fingerprint showed up
on the on the uh on the purse of the
third woman that he killed so we stopped
him after three
we have a bunch of those that easily
could have been serial murders that used
to afflict New York in in the past
you've got to look for the secondary
um
characteristics that predict that you're
going to have more crime or the other
way they describe that is the broken
windows Theory but they when they say
the broken windows Theory it sounds like
something silly like you know you
enforce uh people who are spitting on
the sidewalk or
no you look at uh what would be minor
crimes that are indicia of a
neighborhood starting to turn
to much more dangerous crime and you do
enforcement of that and cut it out at an
early stage and it's a lot of it is
um study and hard work and prediction
and statistics I never would have been
able to reduce crime the way I did 30
years earlier without the computer
because we never would have been able to
analyze the statistics fast enough
to turn them around and use them
to uh to act that's so weird because we
have better Predictive Analytics
technology today better data better than
everybody we should be better at this
100 better at it instead instead most of
our politicians particularly Democrats
engage in uh propaganda about about
about crime like how about this um
a cop got shot the other day Adams shows
up and says we've got to get the guns
off the street
we've got to enforce we've got to have
stronger gun control laws now Adams was
a cop
what what by Nature what is the criminal
a criminal is a person whose Behavior
can't be controlled
because of his behave it could be
controlled he wouldn't have shot
somebody
so a criminal is not going to listen or
obey the gun control was neither is a
Madman
so gun control might be good or bad it
has nothing to do with reducing crime
because criminals don't respond to
controls
they're uncontrollable that's by nature
and the more dangerous they are the more
uncontrollable they are so it's a
fantasy world to think that gun control
which may be good to reduce suicides or
accidental murders
has anything to do with crime you want
to go debate it
debate it based on its safer
you should have some of these controls
because of the accidental murders that
take place but you're not gonna you
could have all the gun control in the
world which they have in Chicago
in which they have in New York and you
can have massive number of murders Pat
if I could just add one other thing
because I researched for my last book
this very question and my answer I
basically wrote a chapter about you the
first thing that the mayor did and
correct me if I'm wrong I grew up in
Long Island so we had to come through
the Midtown Tunnel to get into the city
my grandparents lived in the city the
first thing that he did basically we had
all those guys that were standing
outside the Midtown Tunnel and they were
washing your windows with dirty water
and it set a tone for when you got into
the city so the Suburban people would
come into the city the first thing that
would happen they were basically
accosted by some version of homeless
people or whatever it might be he
immediately got rid of those people then
started cleaning up Times Square and
then suddenly all the other people that
lived in the other boroughs started
coming in and realizing oh it's kind of
clean here and then people it's what's
happening here in Florida you start
modeling something good and then people
because people are waiting for a model
all the time they don't just do it on
their own but you start getting rid of
the people that are just annoying
everybody and bother everybody and
making things dirty and uncomfortable
and next thing you know everyone else
starts to quote Jordan Peterson standing
up with their shoulders back right and
that actually is what happened and then
we had 20 incredible years I was there
for virtually I was there for all of
your mayorship Kelly carried it on and
improved it Tom your thoughts when
you're hearing this how are you
processing what he just said right now
well I I have some first-hand experience
with San Francisco a chapter in my
career you know I lived in East Bay I
took Bart from Castro Valley to
Embarcadero and Montgomery station
there's two stations right there and I
worked at 525 Market and everything Soma
South the market you know today you hear
about all these issues and I've seen it
so I've seen San Francisco before and
after and I want to know do you think
Rudy that there's also going to be some
faith in the voters the voters in San
Francisco recalled the district attorney
about a year ago now have they got a
better district attorney we're about to
find out
because it's it's coming to a head you
also have commercial space right now
occupancy and pricing and of commercial
real estate space is dropping in San
Francisco and it's not coveted and it's
not the recession it's at San Francisco
now freaking sucks and nobody wants to
put their business there and put their
people there and now we've lost a leader
from one of the pillars of San Francisco
which is the tech industry and so is
there some faith that you can put in the
voters can the voters turn the tide they
recalled the D.A the mayor is not has
been tenuously
tenuous popularity right now the mayor
which is about to go sideways because a
week ago no no not even a week it was
four days four days before the murder
the mayor punts now I think we all read
about San Francisco that they've deep
criminalized drug use you can actually
use needles you can be right there on
the street and they will not arrest them
well now the mayor has got such issues
going on with families leaving
uh
businesses leaving commercial real
estate vacancy had all these things kind
of cries uncle and asked for federal
dollars to help with the drug problem in
San Francisco joining drug problem in
San Francisco you're handing out needles
and it got worse what a shock I gave
whiskey and car keys to my son and I
wrecked the car I'm so surprised right
why are you surprised now you're crying
for federal dollars that this is true
I'm not exaggerating this saying it's
we're overrun the problems overrun and
we have so many vacancies for law
enforcement we can't fill them of course
because they don't want to why do you
want to be I'll be a California highway
patrolman in Central State why would I
say instead of doing that I'm going to
take a job in San Francisco where
there's no bullets in my gun right I'm
just supposed to show it and scare
people
you you sit there and you look at this
so I look at it and I say is there a
moment where we the people can kind of
stand up and demand change they've
recalled the D.A but is there a tide is
it because you're talking about a smart
person yourself with support from the
mayor's office and from we the people
and you're able to implement the things
you're talking about if it wasn't the
case you wouldn't have been there long
if they said oh this is too terrible
he's this is this is bad you're being
hard on youth all those things in the BS
that goes with that do you think there's
a tide that can turn in San Francisco
for the citizenry even though they are
very liberal on social matters look
around at the crime and what's happened
to their City
they've recalled the D.A do you think
there's a point where the people can say
enough and can start voting in favor of
being against the people that are
getting support from Sorrows
I I hate to say it I don't know it was
true 30 years ago
uh
when I got elected some other people got
elected people just were tired of the
crime and the but you look at Chicago
the other day that never should have
happened in Chicago
um
I don't know I don't know if the will is
there or or there's been such a change
in the in the attitude and I'm not
talking about America now I'm talking
about cities
I mean uh uh there was an article today
or yesterday basically saying San
Francisco has passed the turning point
and it's gone
uh it's a very fatalistic attitude I
hate that I mean I'm always an optimist
but so I would I would say sure there's
a chance if you elect if you elect an
independent person a a very strong
person and a person doesn't mind getting
criticized and uh evaluates themselves
you know on honest principles uh and
there are people like that and
occasionally you can vote for someone
like that but they're not the usual
person that runs for for office you get
that person particularly a mayor a mayor
a mayor in New York in particular has
great power for good or bad uh more
power in a way in your little domain
than the president has to change things
so yeah I mean if we if next time we
elect the right person for mayor you
could turn around New York
I think I'm not sure the San Francisco's
too far gone I hate to tell you San
Francisco doesn't need Harvey Dent it
needs Batman that that's the situation
it may be too far gone yeah I don't know
okay I think Chicago's too far gone I
think they just indicated that yeah by
the way I have the stats for the cities
when you go through the cities with the
biggest crime and you look at top 20 I
have it somewhere around here when we
were going through it it I think what
was it 27 out of 30 top cities in
America are ran by Democratic Mayors so
when you're going back and I asked a
question from you and the first thing
you said is I don't know if the question
is right because it's about politics
you're making me think about the fact
that it depends on where their policies
lie for them to execute the right thing
but here's here's one thing I would say
for the person that's watching this okay
we had a person that we're talking about
hey my kids are going to the school you
know what do I do about it I said listen
there's different levels of parenting
there's those parents that are oblivious
of what's going on in school like just
they just don't give a [__] they don't
pay attention like ah whatever then
there's those parents that are they know
what's going on they [__] and complain
they're not happy about it but they just
talk they don't do anything then the
third level of people is the people that
say I know what's going on I care about
it and I'm gonna run for board because
there's only a five percent uh turnout
I'm gonna go and do something about it
then the fourth step is hey I have tried
I did try to do something other parents
were not for it I've decided to you know
move to a different state okay then the
other option is I'm gonna do
homeschooling or I'm going to put them
in private school if you can afford it
right there's certain things to it if
somebody is watching this and you're
saying I wish my mayor in my city would
do this this is my suggestion to you
this part of the podcast that we just
had we're going to put a clip to it
right what mayor's suggestion was I
would share this part with as many
people in your city as possible
including with your mayor and the people
in the office and say hey here's a case
study of a guy in the last 50 years that
was able to do it better than anybody
else I don't want to leave my city I
love my city why don't we set aside the
politics whether you like this man or
not he did something in a city that
cleaned up the streets you and I were
having lunch at this restaurant over
here in in Angelo's and the owner was
there and he came up I can't even tell
you how the reaction was we're sitting
there you know and all of a sudden he's
like Tom you remember this he comes in
and he says mayor Giuliani I have to
tell you you are my hero I am Italian I
grew up in the streets I remember how
you cleaned up the streets we felt safe
for kids myself everybody you are my
hero he's saying this to him while we're
sitting having regular lunch together
and a lot of other people feel that way
as well so my suggestion whatever City
you're in San Francisco LA Baltimore shy
Town whatever it is shared as part of
the message and maybe you can be the
voice the leader to help that City get
some good ideas there again how many
guys left today's podcast by the way
okay
for those of you guys that are watching
out there we wish you were here with us
we got some complaints from some people
saying Patrick it's as if you keep this
as a secret we did not know how to buy
tickets if you want to make sure you get
tickets next time to be able to register
for the next podcast when we announce a
live one text award podcast to
310-340-1132 text award podcast
310-340-1132 to be informed because when
we announced these the premier tickets
sell out within it for seven minutes
these guys don't even wait they just
goes bam gone and then the other ones
kind of take a little bit longer to sell
out but the first one goes out fast
we're gonna put the link below to both
the mayor's podcast on how to follow his
show it'll be below if you liked what he
had to say today he does this every day
you can watch them on a daily basis he's
got to show the links will be below Rob
let's make sure we post that in the chat
as well as a description as well as Dave
Rubin if you like what he have to say
he's got a big Channel and he creates
content regularly and it's coming from a
very good place both of them are going
to put the link below as well for you to
go out there and and listen to his
podcast as well gentlemen Dave uh uh
mayor uh thank you so much for coming
out this was a wonderful time Tom thank
you for your Insight Adam thank you for
the Insight on the cats we will never
forget it I think it was an incredible
marketing strategy to the folks here
stick around because we're going to do q
a here everybody else out there if you
enjoyed the show today please subscribe
to the channel take care everybody
okay
this was awesome
so
you need to write use a restroom feel
free to go and use a restroom and come
back this part's going to be about 30
minutes but just for